So this is the first one ever live.
Is it?
It says offline.
Let's see.
Do,
do,
do.
There's probably a bit of a delay,
right?
Just like youtube or youstream rather.
So starting it says offline to me though.
Say offline.
Do you,
oh,
here we go.
Something's happening.
I see a spinning wheel.
Proud Mary.
Keep on burning.
Big Wheel.
Keep on turning.
Nope.
Yes.
Success.
Steven Crowder.
You are the first official broadcast streamed live on not a good sign.
It's a great sign.
Why is that bad?
Well,
you're going to turn,
yeah,
you're gonna get some monsters on youtube.
We'll show you a fag.
Makes appearances quite a bit.
When I appear I'm not Jewish or gay.
Did someone call you?
Would you bag all the time?
Yeah.
Hmm.
You look just funny cause I'm not Jewish or gay.
My brother and I did a video when youtube,
it just started,
it was 2006 so I don't know if you remember,
was a rash of really bad impression videos.
It would be like I'm going to do a hundred impressions and it was some guy doing
like Kermit the frog.
Cartoons are not impressions,
you're just doing cartoon voices like at a party.
And so I did one where I did these impressions that were really mediocre but my
brother was my ed McMahon and he was just laughing his ass.
He just thought it was hilarious and then it goes on for like five minutes and
then I do a pretty spot on Harrison Ford impression and brothers like you need
it,
you need to work on that one a little bit.
And so we have these,
this is the new youtube was new uncensored and it's like you're a Jew Fag and I
hope you get aids from that Jew fag not realizing he was my brother.
My brother is not Jewish either and that there were people who hated it because
they thought the impressions were awful.
There were people who hated it cause they got the joke and they felt like they'd
been shortchanged and there were people who liked it because they got the joke
in.
There are people who liked it because for some reason they thought the
impressions were good and they were all fighting and we were calling what?
What is this monsters?
Monsters.
Just it in a monsters,
but you do realize that you're feeding those monsters by bringing up their
actual ne like saying all that stuff like you,
you're giving them the attention that they so desperately seek.
Is that like like poltergeist?
Yes.
Eating them like candy man and there's also,
that's a horrible film.
When you go back and watch it at all.
It's like one of those things you watch when you're a kid and you're scared and
you go back.
You're like,
no,
trust me.
Trust me.
Let's watch this.
You watch it with your girlfriend and you just wish you would have left it
there.
Do you know what the one did?
That to me is altered states.
I didn't see altered states.
It was so well those are what got me an isolation tanks.
I was fascinated by and that's what got me into it and he got me into John
Lilly.
The Guy who was the whole movie was actually based on this one guy,
not obviously,
it didn't really turn into a monkey.
Do you remember the movie the William Hurt Movie?
I don't remember the film.
He got ahold of some crazy psychedelic brew from the Amazon Jungle and took it
and brought it back to America and had these experiences where he regressed into
some monkey beast thing and he went to the zoo or kill a bunch of animals.
Yeah.
Like he had like the change,
but when you,
you know,
I was watching it was that,
that's the noise.
I mean I probably was like Larry Flynt
trying to push his wheelchair.
Um,
I watched it when I was like 15 or something like that.
It was in high school and I was like,
Whoa,
this is so cool.
When I watched it again when I was like 39 and I was like,
oh,
this is such a piece of shit that happened with me like two weeks ago with my
wife and I feel ashamed Ninja turtles because it was up late.
And I'm on Netflix,
I'm watching Megan Fox and into term,
I said,
this is terrible.
I get you don't know,
you don't know Ninja turtles because there it was at one point,
it was actually a good film and I take her back and I watched it.
I'm like,
well,
maybe let's try new to turtles too.
And it just gets worse.
Well,
you know the shit that's good when you're little and it's still good when you're
little,
but when you're not little,
it's not good.
Like I took my kids to see this.
Uh,
this is a show called wild Kratts.
Yeah,
well I worked with PBS.
They'd come in every now and then.
Oh yeah.
Arthur was mine.
It's a very good show.
The show is very good.
Like the television show,
the live show is terrible.
Oh,
it's like a museum where you just see a video display kind of deal.
Isn't it like that?
No,
it's worse than that.
It's way worse than that.
It's,
but meanwhile,
my five year old fucking loved it.
Like I took her to see it.
It was a,
at the pantageous in Hollywood and they put on the suits like in the show,
there's this what,
what the show's about.
It's an educational show for people don't know that it is all about wildlife and
kids learn a lot of stuff,
which to be,
is it booma Fu within,
they know they've heard the jumping on the shirt with the grads brothers and um,
uh,
nothing like an actual Lemur.
No.
Very inaccurate.
Yeah,
they can be aggressive,
actual lemurs keys.
So you know,
some kid went to the zoo face torn off by a monkey on red wine and Xanax,
but the um,
the show like my five year old learns all kinds of shit from it because like
she'll say,
you know,
Daddy,
did you know that alligators or crocodiles?
I think it is,
they decide whether or not they're male or female based on the temperature of
the water.
And I'm like,
fuck,
is that true?
And so I Google it.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
My Five Year old just schooled me on crocodile.
The gendered assignment.
I think if we're being honest with ourselves,
your five year old would probably school you on the difference between an
alligator and a crocodile because I'm still murky on it.
I'm pretty clear on that one.
I forget.
Can I get,
you know,
I was like,
Oh,
this crocodile,
it goes by the snouts.
One of them is around her.
Yeah,
alligators.
They don't see,
probably has a lot of respect for the American alligator.
Steve Irwin did.
Yeah,
he was a crocodile hunter,
but I remember when he got around some gators,
he was like,
this is,
don't,
these guys are serious.
Well,
I said,
actually,
alligators are not nearly as aggressive as crocodiles.
Crocodiles are way more dangerous,
and it was factually inaccurate.
It's the opposite.
American alligators are smaller or they're,
well,
they're smaller than crocodile,
like Niall Crocs,
but you know,
they've fucking Douche bags.
Some people have released Nile crocodiles in Florida,
so they found a few of them in the everglades,
and so they have a seek and destroy mission.
Like if you see a Nile crocodile,
like game wardens,
everyone is supposed to kill an onsite to happen in Michigan was Sosa lamp race.
You ever seen those?
Yeah,
and actually as a matter of fact,
I think you've done her show,
Dana Lash and her husband,
they were coming up to my wedding up there and he was like,
I'm not,
I'm not going up there.
They got lampreys in the light come like they have no sharks,
they have no sting rays.
You have land praise that's a J.
It's scary.
It's got like a mouth full of teeth.
They're cool.
They're like,
yeah,
but they're not pleasant to be in the water with.
But they've exterminated like I think 90 something percent of them.
But it's that 10% that you still have to worry about up there in the Great
Lakes.
Yeah.
Well there's a bunch of invasive species from other countries that they've done
that with those uh,
Asian carp.
That's one of them.
Yeah.
If you haven't seen that folks,
you got to Google it because it's the craziest fucking thing you could.
There's a youtube videos for whatever reason.
When you ride boats they jump out of the water and they have knocked people dead
like knock people out called they jump out of the water.
He actually died from Asian carp.
I bet people have died cause I know people have been knocked out cold.
I know,
I know personally.
A lot of weight.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You're like 30 pounds.
They fucking jumping in the air and make them sharp.
So I'll do that.
You know?
Really?
Yeah.
Mako sharks can get,
I mean maybe you can bring it up like I want to say 60 miles an hour or
something absurd and they'll go right into boats.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Maaco sharks.
So they just slam into but,
but they don't get on fishing boats.
Yeah,
they'll actually like cause just going so fast and I think they're coming for
the bait.
You can find videos if you bring them up.
Have you ever seen the video of the kayakers that get fucking swamped by the
whale?
The whale breaching.
Read Moby Dick.
Now this is a real one.
This is a real ones.
A real one.
They should get.
See if he can find that.
The whale a swamp.
Some kayakers.
Yeah.
These fucking poor fools are out in a kayak.
I love whales.
It's amazing to see in this environment when you're around nature,
it just makes you feel so wonderful.
They care about us.
They look,
there's fucking,
well,
I'll just
show these poor fuckers isn't fluid.
Watch this shit.
Is it?
Where did I go this way?
This one.
Anyone either the mat push this.
Oh my gosh.
Kyla,
you fucked up son.
Kill them all.
That's one thing I talked about.
I remember someone really mad in stand up a bit about sharks.
I was like,
let's just sit close of a Jesus fucking Christ.
Oh Gosh.
I mean that's got away.
What?
10,000 pounds a dead or do they just kind of move with it because it's water?
I mean,
if that happened to land your dead.
Yeah,
I would assume they just move with it.
I mean,
they probably got fucked.
The real scary thing is if you get knocked unconscious by the blow and then you
go look at,
that's the impact of it.
Oh,
my fucker was a hunchback.
What do we know?
No big.
Oh,
there it looks like they're okay.
Have you ever seen wheels from real life?
Oh,
there they are.
The dolphins.
Uh,
I don't think I've seen whales.
I've seen whales.
I went on a,
one of the,
one of the things my daughter had this a school thing where you go over to a
Zuma,
Zuma beach,
like somewhere around November.
I think they start and you don't even believe what you're seeing,
right?
You seem in the Wadi,
like that's a fucking,
that's a real whale.
Yeah.
Like you see them and you're like,
oh my,
well,
I guess it's like when you see them on TV go,
yeah,
they're big.
I get it.
But when you see them in real life and you get a perspective,
you're like,
oh my God,
they're just living out there.
Well,
it's like Lena Dunham.
You see her in the pictures and you know what's bad and then you see her in
context next to someone.
I see what you just see what I did there.
Case she blocked me quickly without me ever even tweeting her.
One thing I will say we were in Florida blocks you because of that video that
you made.
Is that what it was?
No,
she won't me long before that video.
Really.
I get blocked by people before I even talked to them.
I do too.
Sometimes I'm proud of it.
Well,
a lot of them are comedians too.
Just comedians.
Black.
You get the fuck out of here.
What comedians and block to Amy Schumer?
Mark Marin.
I never tweeted them.
What?
Same insurance.
I got in an argument,
a on Fox News a long time ago.
No,
about what?
About a column I wrote and we got into it and I was like,
okay.
And I was,
it was actually pretty respectful,
but I,
it happens with a lot of Comedians,
a lot of comics.
What was the column about?
The column was about how as a Christian and how I wasn't having sex and wrote
about sort of the case for Christians maybe aren't crazy who wait until they're
married and she's like,
I feel like it's really judgmental and really harsh.
And I was like,
okay,
well that's fine.
This is my case and you don't have to do it.
She got really,
really mad about it.
You know what's interesting is if you are like a tantric Buddhist,
that's exactly what I said.
Yeah,
I talked about that cause and right away off air.
The first thing,
and it's the same thing with with Marin who I,
you know I like,
um,
is well where do you do?
You're not part of our club.
Are you a comedian?
He does that though.
He did that with me and he's got this weird thing we were going to fly.
She goes,
she goes,
well where do you perform standup?
You forming the city and this point I was living in New York.
I was like,
no,
she was woody before.
I'm like,
you're a Christian like churches.
I said,
no actually,
but that sounded like a great idea.
So then after that I started calling up churches like,
do you do stand up?
And there was one that responded.
Yes.
Um,
and then I was,
I was,
they complain and I never did another church again cause I had like,
I had a whole bit about not having sex and the,
I wrote with that it's the final taboo.
Like I can go up and be as profane as possible.
Right.
And I follow comedians or I'll go up and it's filthy and my act is very
politically incorrect.
Like I've been banned from places but it's not dirty.
And I said,
then I go up and talk about not having sex and I won't get so uncomfortable.
The church problem was that I talked about having a raging erection for four
years where my family had to lift the furniture,
like a great Danes tail.
So the church,
is that a problem with it?
So you,
you did this for years,
he didn't have sex.
Yeah,
for years.
Why did you do that?
Cause I didn't want to be a hypocrite.
And so in what way?
Well,
as someone who is a Christian,
I don't really talk about it a lot,
but I was like,
you know,
and I don't want to be,
I don't want to be a target that easily as far as being a hypocrite and I,
that's why I did it.
So sex,
like there's a lot of really right off the bat.
Yeah.
Because this is a,
it's so,
it's a wacky subject,
you know,
like as a discipline,
like there's some beautiful things about Christianity as a discipline,
but the problem is as a practice,
if you,
if you really pay attention to the scriptures themselves,
it's so problematic.
There's so many contradictions is so much crazy shit in there.
You going on the Old Testament.
Well,
if that's the case,
you're,
you're talking about some really nutty shit.
If you want on the New Testament,
I want to get off,
I'm going to wells in this right off the bat,
but you know what I'm saying?
I understand what testament mice are created by Constantine.
A bunch of the Canon was really manufacturing.
He wasn't even a Christian.
And here's my,
is on his deathbed.
I don't talk about it a lot.
I'll write about it because it's,
it's a big part of what defines me.
Like we'd Harrison Greenbaum on and you know,
norm Macdonald's Harrison Greenbaum went up and he did this bit about,
you know,
someone read me a scripture from a book,
on the,
on the bus.
And I said,
well,
if you get to quote your favorite book,
I get 12 mine Harry Potter batch.
And he came on and he was really Harrison Greenbaum.
He's on last comic standing.
Anyways,
he was on the show.
He claimed,
he said he knew you and they had him on.
He was really mad that I wrote gay comic gets sort of shafted by norm.
And he was like,
he was like,
well,
you know,
first off he used gay pejoratively.
I said,
yes.
He goes,
well,
okay,
so you know what that means?
I said,
sure,
you're a comedian,
right?
Like why is that a problem?
But he goes,
well,
you know,
first of you just didn't use it pejoratively and you didn't even ask me.
I said,
well,
are you gay?
He goes,
no.
Okay.
And I said,
okay,
I'll take your word for it,
but I don't believe you,
but let's just continue with the interview.
And we went out.
And then afterwards I was like,
I was like,
you know,
the fact is,
even if you're not gay,
you make this Christian joke but you don't touch Islam at all.
And I know you claim you're straight,
but they would throw you off a roof for your lisp.
And He,
um,
the thing with norm was he went out,
he did this bit about the Bible and you have Roseanne Barr on last comic
standing.
And my commentary was just the norm said,
you know,
I didn't think it was a,
and I think it was accurate and I didn't think it was funny it up.
And I didn't think it was risky and I thought it was very safe.
And if you're going to sell to the entire group of people who,
you know,
I know about the faith,
you should probably know what you're talking about.
That was it.
Right.
And he was so upset and he was like,
he was going,
well,
the audience is actually booming,
norm.
And I go,
well,
you're missing the point of the piece.
It's that everyone was upset at norm saying that.
And Roseanne Barr's telling her that some Rascii Shat when he'd made a Bible
joke and is pointing out,
it's really not that risky.
Well,
what was the joke?
Do you remember?
What was a quiet guy quoting scripture?
He said,
my favorite.
The Harry Potter batch.
Yeah,
that's something he's not gay.
He's gay as fuck.
If he's,
if he sounds anything like your voice,
it's like,
well this is the one,
can I look at Harrison Greenbaum,
pull them up on the screen and bring up our interview with,
I will tell you by looking,
I have that,
that gift.
That's true.
Got that gift from Jesus.
Wait,
did you look at him?
I can look at,
tell them someone and find out their guy.
Well that's not gay Dar cause that's a gift.
It's a biblical or divine friend.
Uh,
David Pride says that's a homo vision.
Well he should,
he should go on TV and say that this is the guy,
he'll do well.
Okay.
That guy's not game.
Hmm.
We can't go buy a picture.
Yes,
I can just like that.
The sweater with the white shirt.
A nice guy to be
gay.
I don't think there's anything wrong with being good point was he got mad and he
didn't want me to take him out of context.
So I said,
okay,
we'll do a pre tape.
We have to do two segments for Aaron.
We did like a three hour thing on it where I was doing with it.
So where was this interview being held?
Is My show.
Oh,
your show.
Okay.
So he came on your show.
Yeah.
All right.
We're going to slip in a request for you to go on.
You can not say no,
but now I do it.
Sure.
It's um,
we know we go terrestrially actually we're going,
um,
into syndication here with the Alex Jones's.
Same guys at Genesis doesn't mean I agree with Alex and a whole bunch.
But uh,
so we kind of have the show that's syndicated terrestrially and then we do
extended versions for the podcast.
We're kind of bridging that gap.
Well Alex is the exact opposite of you in,
in the sense of,
uh,
Alex is not,
not having sex for any reason whatsoever.
I'm married though.
He's a fucking animal.
He's a crazy dude.
Like people go,
why are you friends with I was John's.
I go,
I'm friends with Alex Jones Cause I'm friends with Alex Jones.
What you're getting,
it's Alex Jones on Info wars.com.
What they're doing right now,
take away life.
They want to wipe out America.
You know,
he,
he's,
he's gonna do impressions in your act or do you find it hard to bring them in?
I very rarely do it.
Feels hacked to bring them in and stand up.
Usually it doesn't it,
well,
unless it's,
there's a reason to do it.
Like if I,
if I have to do a Mike Tyson bit,
if there's something happens and Mike Tyson and I've got a bit that does it.
Well you saw it from like 1991 there's something that's online but it,
there's a reason to do a voice.
I'll do it.
Right.
You're like if I had a bill Cosby bed,
do bill Cosby's voice.
We do what we do on the podcast.
So we do fake commercials.
We like dating advice with Bill Cosby,
minute news minute with the in a nick of time with Nick Nolte d.
So it's like the Internet is actually,
it's funny we were talking about this when stand up,
I started standing,
I started acting actually when I was 12 and then I did stand up because the
unions killed the industry in Montreal.
There was just no more film coming into the city.
You know,
they used to shoot a ton of stuff in Montreal.
Now not so much.
And so I was in my teens and I had been writing standup for years for like
school talent shows.
Like,
I think this would be funny because I grew up around it and I thought it was so
freeing to do it.
And then it's kind of turned like you were talking about this PC culture where I
think,
and I was sort of wrong in a sense,
I was like,
these kids online,
they're not,
they're not comedians.
They don't know what it's like.
But I think about it,
you know,
that's what the Marx brothers would have set of standup.
It's just an evolution of comedy and you can't do stand up in your bedroom,
but you can do youtube and your bedroom.
And so you look like at at Nicole Arbor,
this thing,
I don't know if you saw she was,
did the fat shaming thing.
I did see the,
and I didn't think was prickly funny,
but I defended the right to say it,
but I was saying it doesn't matter if she's funny or not because people will
always attack you for not being funny.
I'm not going to say that's offensive.
You can't say it.
They'll say,
well,
I just,
you're just not funny.
So you shouldn't be able to say that.
And a PC,
you know,
the PC culture has really permeated,
stand up in a way that's,
I mean,
it happened in Canada years ago.
Yeah.
It's freedom of speech doesn't really exist in Canada.
It's not a legally protected,
right.
Well,
you know about the guy in Vancouver who literally got sued and lost because he
had some woman heckling him and he said a bunch of mean shit to her.
And so he,
whatever human rights violation,
I forget what the actual citation was.
Yeah.
But he has to pay like $15,000.
Well,
there's a pastor Steven blossom who,
um,
said he wouldn't marry two guys and spoke out against it and it wasn't hateful.
You know,
everyone loves to paint pastors to southern preop am Hamas.
Right.
And he was just like,
well listen,
that's not going to happen to my church.
And um,
he was actually banned from public speaking losses.
Church had to file an appeal.
And so that's where,
when I talk with people about it,
you know,
I think it was sent from public speaking by saying that he doesn't want to marry
gate and saying it's still against gods.
You know,
whatever his deal is,
what do you agree with it or not?
That's my point.
It's still not okay to ban a guy from even having a church.
I mean,
Westboro Baptists have 12 people,
nine of whom are the guy's family.
They get so much press time.
Meanwhile,
we have over 300 million Muslims who want you to die for converting,
and we're talking about the Westboro Baptist because they use the f word.
It's fun reasons why the Westboro Baptist Church means that Guy Phelps was so
fucking nuts.
He was so out of it.
Did you ever see the the Louis Theroux documentaries where they ask if he's
Jewish?
He's like,
well,
I don't think it should matter,
but are you do,
I'm not saying I'm,
I'm,
I am Jewish,
but I don't understand why that should,
that's not relevant.
Are you Jew?
That was all,
it was like the guy on youtube,
that kind of student Brazilian Jiu Jitsu do remember that.
I don't remember that.
The white supremacists,
why do I not remember?
They were training in Brazilian Jujitsu and I was like,
do you not see fee?
They were training MMA,
Brazilian Jujitsu,
the the,
we know,
wait,
no,
I'm thinking of a different one with through on white supremacists.
Oh,
let me get a white supremacist.
While I didn't see that and they were like training up their gang and they were
doing Brazilian Jujitsu that well that's pretty ironic.
I Brazilians are not white.
You fuck,
well they kind of are.
Some of them are,
but they're the most racist people on the planet.
Brazilians.
Oh my God.
Well I wouldn't say they're racist.
What I would say is that they're nationalistic,
they're very nationalistic,
but they're,
but they're not in the sense because there's like half the country is black,
like half the country is,
is like well can,
I don't know if you really sort of,
not to get into your wheelhouse,
but like the,
the,
the tour Belfour Anderson Silva thing.
If you look at a lot of the stuff like in the Brazilian message boards that
people were saying,
it was really like this short of coming up of this black class in Brazil where
if you were black,
you worked at Mcdonald's,
you just weren't considered a first class citizen among a lot of the pure
Brazilians and people don't understand about Che Guevara in the,
in,
um,
Cuba,
same kind of thing.
You know,
I saw a kid wearing a chicken bear shirt.
I go,
well,
let me just,
where Hitler shirt or what do you mean?
He believed in pure European Spanish blood and executed people for not being
that,
um,
and uh,
in Brazil to really is a class structure.
I mean,
my Brazilian instructor,
I won't say who I've had several was quite racist and he's like,
oh man,
he ain't America.
You could play 45.
The Guy,
he's,
he's white.
You black in Brasil,
he's not even give time of day.
He was,
that's weird because shock ray is like a Brazilian national hero and he's black,
but they're out pay rates.
What about Palae?
The soccer player.
He was a Brazilian national hero.
He was black.
And my evidence is anecdotal,
Joe.
Oh No.
Yeah,
no it is true.
I've been to Brazil many times.
They're free.
I just don't see that.
I mean I might be wrong,
you know there was a,
there was a huge issue with Anderson Silva when he flipped Damien Maia.
Yeah.
And you know,
and he was a sort of bores was he class?
Damien had college,
he would call the order.
Playboy.
Playboy is like one of the ways that they,
they,
that's the majority of the use for rich privileged white people.
Right.
You know,
playboy,
check your privilege.
Check my friend,
my friend check for you.
I don't know.
I would have to,
I'd never actually asked my Brazilian friends whether or not Brazil's racist,
but I didn't experience it that much when I was there.
They'd seem real friendly.
It's a very,
very friendly country other than the broken stuff that helps to understand like,
like,
you know,
success has changed how people treat.
You're very successful.
You're a victim of your own success in a sense.
There's a sense I came in here,
nervous.
Well they also know that I'm a Brazilian Jiu Jitsu black belt.
So I,
I practice Brazilian arts.
Big Deep respect for Brazil Groin and then big deep respect for of course the
Gracie family mean I'm wearing a fucking crazy.
The Gracie family.
We
thank you
Harry Potter batch.
Um,
it is weird though that like there's not a straight voice,
you know,
but there's a gay voice.
Yeah.
And what's so fun?
It's like you say that my wife had a friend,
I won't talk about it.
Talk about it.
You don't have to name names.
Who was clearly gay?
Oh,
I got and got to the point where when he was gone I would call them gay blank
because I know it's such a common name.
My wife was just free.
I'm going to get a text right now so she'd be like,
I was out with so and so on,
but gay so and so,
cause I know five of them,
you know,
it's just like,
it's like a name like John.
It's not John,
but he's not gay.
Okay.
First off,
I said,
let,
let me,
let me clarify the rules.
If he's not gay,
you can't go out with him alone until one in the morning.
Okay,
he's gay.
And I'd be like,
that was so at many,
sure enough,
he like came out of the closet was shocker.
Well here's the thing,
when a guy like that,
and I mean literally like he's the kind of gay guy who literally like Richard
Simmons would be like,
well that's kind of severe,
like really gay.
And um,
when he came out of the closet,
I told my wife,
I said,
okay,
here's what's going on.
What he's really saying is,
stuff's about to get weird.
You're going to find some grinder profiles.
Like,
cause everyone knew he was gay,
right.
And then all of a sudden it's just a revolving door of boyfriends and it's like,
it's more uncomfortable for my wife.
It's more comfortable for me because I had to keep this lie alive.
Like,
Hey,
you go on any dates with females lately?
Gay Black like now,
you know,
and he dated a girl for a while and I remember just sitting there like,
what bunny hole it,
I jump into where I'm sitting at dinner with my wife and gay blank with his girl
and they're clearly just faking it.
And I was like,
I just wrapped the girl faking it or what did she think that maybe he was
straight or question?
I have a friend,
my friend Shane,
Natasha,
a standup comedian.
She's married,
not one but two different guys that turned out to be gay.
Like she married at a certain point.
It's you.
Well,
I don't know if it's her.
I mean,
I don't know what the fuck is.
She seemed so normal though.
I mean,
she's a comic.
She's Kinda crazy.
But she's nice.
She's,
she seems totally normal.
I have not met him.
I talked to stable female comedians.
I know a few.
Well,
it's weird because it's like in my world,
you know,
like in my world,
in the world of stand up in my world,
sunny,
my patriarchal world,
the sun sets on the west and rises in the Eaton.
It's actually,
does that right?
Yeah,
I reverted back.
it was accurate.
My world's boring frankly.
But the world of standup comics,
it's like there's,
it's a fraternity,
you know,
so like I'm friends with girls who are open Micros,
I'm friends with like especially from kill Tony,
which is a one of my friend red band.
And um,
Tony Hinchcliffe shows where we constantly around these open miker kids that are
coming up and you know,
we've become friends with them and a lot of them are out of their fucking mind.
They're crazy,
but they're friends.
You know,
in my world,
those are ditches.
That's just the mindset that it takes to be a comedian.
You have to be a little bit fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I think that's true.
There's just thing.
So,
so Shayma is no different than any of my other friends in that sense.
But somehow or another,
she wound up with two fucking gay guys.
And the last time I talked to her,
I don't think that story goes somehow or another.
I think there's a reason and they need her mind.
It's somehow or another,
she's like,
what the fuck?
But you know,
she's dated straight guys.
She didn't,
one of my buddies,
I mean she,
you know,
it's not that,
I don't know what the fuck it is,
but she did it.
One guy and then she found out somehow and I think he was gay and then she did
it.
Another guy that was like a male stripper I think.
And somehow or another he was doing with,
there you go.
It's kind of like the talent pool with college sports.
You're picking the guy with the highest vertical.
She's drawn from the pool of the male strippers and the guys who are,
you know,
pay for gay bodybuilders.
That's what's going to happen.
Hey,
for a gay bar,
Gay for pay,
they say,
well it depends on who's doing the pain.
Got called.
He's the one who's paying for the gay.
Is that true?
I have no idea.
It was going to want to be slandered.
Please.
That what you heard?
You heard Joe Wieder paid Arnold?
I didn't hear that.
I knew that.
I heard that Arnold.
I could've been [inaudible] shit back in the day.
I could be completely off base.
Well,
I've talked about it on the podcast.
I had a buddy who was a male stripper,
two buddies,
but way back in the day.
And uh,
you know,
where these uh,
underwear that was like a,
it was a like a,
um,
an elephant underwear and he put his hog and the trunk and even now you combine
your hog with elephant is one animal,
another.
It's actually like a delicacy.
Really.
The guy was really fucking weird.
But then one day and just talking about all these girls that he's dancing for
and I go,
you ever have to dance for guys?
And this is fucking silence in the room.
And everybody's asking why he wants to keep alive.
He said it,
he asked the question and then check out weird when you started explaining how
he had to sometimes,
but he hated it.
And you're like,
when I moved to La,
there was a rope,
there was work and it was cleaning.
I was,
when I moved to La,
I was talking.
Yeah,
Tony Camacho was my manager.
And,
um,
I was living out of a car for a bit.
And when I say it's Kinda like the Ronda Rousey,
it was like a week and I was just sort of couch surfing until I got to my next
place.
So it's not like I was a longtime Hobo.
Right.
And actually got a 24 hour fitness pass for like a week,
so I was fine.
Um,
I don't even know how I was getting started.
Something about,
Oh yeah,
there was a role in,
in,
in craigslist and it was like cleaning houses in your underwear of this.
It was like no contact,
but you're just cleaning houses and your underwear.
It's like 150 bucks an hour or something like that.
Like,
no,
no wait,
it was $50 an hour for a minimum of three hour pay because it is assumed,
you know,
I lost something under the couch.
Yes.
Well my dad had that,
he mowed lawns and the guy at an Indian village in Detroit and he would,
my dad could maybe text me the name of this guy and he said,
the guy was like,
but he wasn't flamboyantly gay.
He was very polite.
He was like,
well,
you know,
Darren,
you're a good looking young man.
You and your brother Dean,
you should,
uh,
as you move along,
you know,
feel free.
It's,
it's hot here in the summer to take off your shirts and wear something a little
bit shorter.
And,
uh,
it's,
it's entirely,
you know,
if you want to take a dip in the pool,
go ahead.
Oh boy.
But he was very,
very nice.
They had a light longterm partner and uh,
you know,
I think a lot of them got massacred in Detroit.
I don't think they live in that area anymore.
Really massacred.
Well,
I just mean Detroit.
It's a war zone there Indians,
some sort of fucking native American war.
He came over together,
indigenous,
Ken,
sandy and anymore.
Is that a no,
you can only can't say Indian.
We moved on the native American and now we moved on to indigenous.
Hmm.
Well,
in Canada it's Digitas,
right?
First nation.
So they say,
I don't know what they st they say for I left Canada.
Well,
it used to be you.
everybody called people ask them all and then,
no,
you can't do that.
You can't.
But in Alaska,
they use the word Eskimo.
Like it's okay.
Alaska.
It's okay.
It's weird.
This is the problem with a lexicon and the changing rules.
Well,
it's when people get ultra super fucking sensitive and shit gets weird.
Like there's things that used to say for the longest time and now you can't say
him anymore.
Yeah.
Well,
and that's where,
you know,
you're more in the middle.
Uh,
I'm,
you know,
people would say to the right of Attila the Hun,
like Libertarian,
conservative.
Um,
and that's by design.
That's,
that's not an accident.
People want to control language.
If you look at the history of political correctness,
it is designed as a political tool.
And I see these people awakening now,
like the social justice warrior left.
Well,
all they're doing is doing the same thing to,
maybe they're not doing it to you,
but the people like Milo to people out there who are liberal,
the same thing they've done to me and every conservative for a long time.
You're a racist.
You're a sexist.
Perfect example is Ben Carson.
You may not like him.
People may not like them,
right.
But Ben Carson was a neurosurgeon but not just in neuro.
So the best,
he was a fucking wizard and um,
he's probably the most polite candidate we've had in 40 years.
I don't think anyone would dispute that.
He's a very polite guy.
What do they do?
They paint him as a dumb ass bigot.
Well he believes some crazy shit.
Some crazy stuff.
Yeah.
But I would hope that people afford him.
You know,
for example,
like my dad is Christian conservative,
right?
But he sends your stuff along and now he could easily be like,
ah,
you know,
he,
it'll just tell them like us get through the edible mushrooms stuff and the
tattoos cause doesn't agree with it.
But like Joe is really right on this,
the part about,
about dying to the ego everyday in Brazilian Jiu Jitsu and I'll send it along to
people that this is really inspirational for in my family.
We've never had to paint someone as an idiot because of some opinions with which
we don't agree.
You may think Ben Carson believes some crazy stuff,
but he's a smart guy and he's not a bigot.
Well,
what I find fascinating about him is the people that do compartmentalize certain
aspects of life like that.
He does ignore science when it comes to evolution and he believes in macro
evolution,
but it doesn't believe in micro evolution.
I believe the other way around.
Micro but not macro.
But he's got some interesting ideas about what he believes in,
what he doesn't believe in that the world of science accepts as a,
as a state.
In fact,
the people that are,
but I know a lot of people say,
oh,
he's this 6,000 year old young Earth creationist,
you know,
and they,
and he said,
no,
I'm not.
He just said he has flaws in the big bang and he believes in a big bang.
Just a very different version of it.
Well,
the big bag,
but I don't think some guy in a reddit thread in his mother's basement with a
bag of Cheetos has figured something out that Ben Carson has it.
You asked me about like the Christian thing.
Well,
you just,
you just diminished a person from reddit.
He just put them in the basement.
I met her parents.
Maybe they have a nice apartment.
Well you get some of those,
you get a weird intersection here cause you get smart people who listened to
your show,
but you do get some close minded people and you,
um,
my thing is,
you know what the reason I don't talk about faith or like Donald Trump,
it's because there are certain things or people just,
they're just not going to hear it.
Here's my position on religion and atheism and I don't think it's an untenable
position.
And it's pretty simple.
I believe there are very smart atheists and I believe that there are some very
smart Christians that's undeniable.
It's undeniable.
Yeah.
But the thing is now the reason atheists are so fun to tease and get them up in
a lab,
there's because they think that all of these brilliant people and 3 billion
people in the face of the earth have missed something that they caught because
they saw a half of a Christopher Hitchens debate.
And if you sit down with Ben Carson,
these kids calling him an idiot and talking about he doesn't know science,
they would sit down and he probably school them.
They may not agree with him,
but he probably schooled them and my promise taking things out of context,
like he's not even my guy.
What you see the problem is you're talking about Ben Carson versus some kids
that don't know what they're talking about,
but if you talk Bernie Sanders or Hillary or a mountain,
but what they're comparing Ben Carson to is people that do know what they're
talking about.
So if you do get people that have a vast understanding of evolution and they sit
down and debate Ben Carson,
he's not going to do very well.
I don't know.
I've not seen it.
I think that I would think probably not,
but I don't think he would put himself in that position.
The Big Bang is the weird one because the big bang,
essentially the no one understands why it happened.
Right.
One understands what caused it.
No one understands if it's just some cycle that goes on every 14 billion years.
Writing a book on it.
Who is Ben Carson on the Big Bang,
unexplained his reasoning.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Well,
what is his reasoning?
Do you know what his position is?
I don't know if anyone's position is.
It doesn't.
It's not.
It doesn't reflect my position,
but I don't think that that disqualifies him from being a better leader than a
lot of people in the docket.
I mean,
did you voice of the Bates last night?
No,
I did not.
There was literally a point where all the biggest argument,
and that's the thing that I have,
if you look at the right,
I mean,
you're moderate,
you would be considered to any leftist if you said the stuff they say,
they'd be like,
Oh,
you're right wing.
That's what they would say.
Not You.
Let's compare really quickly right now the GOP right people.
It's a party of old white guys.
Okay.
You've got Carly Fiorina,
you've got to Latino's and Ted Cruz and Marco Rubio.
You've got a brain surgeries,
barely Latino.
How dare you?
He's gay by the way.
Tech.
Sure.
100%.
Um,
he also was probably one of the smartest students to come out of Harvard from
according to his professor.
It was an Iq that's like higher the Mexican wall.
So they say that that must be it.
So it happened that in chem trails,
um,
I think,
uh,
so you have them Ben Carson,
yet people are career politicians.
You have people with no experience in the political sector.
And then I'm watching last night,
Hillary Clinton,
Bernie Sanders,
O'Malley,
and a couple of other scrubs.
Every single one is an old white politician.
And the worst part is the lack of intellectual diversity.
Look at the GOP debate.
You have rand Paul who's a non-interventionist.
Basically he was all about that cannabis soil.
You have Chris Christie who basically wants to prosecute using drugs.
You have Carly Fiorina who believes it's a states' right.
You have some people who supported the war in Iraq.
You have some people who were against it.
Every single question last night at that democratic debate was answered in
unison and the biggest argument was over who had the lowest rating from the NRA.
They were attacking Bernie Sanders going,
keep in mind you only have a d minus from the NRA.
I got an f.
Is that really what they were arguing about?
Who?
Who said that?
Who was it was O'Malley Sanders and all of them were arguing over who got the
lowest rating of the NRA.
That was their badge of honor.
You only got a d minus.
I'll go to Uf.
I was like,
what is this?
That's interesting because I did see an interview.
I wanted to get to the debate later today.
I didn't watch it yesterday.
I had some stuff I had to do that was actually important.
But um,
Bernie Sanders,
they feel very poor.
Let's talk,
just joking around because I don't,
I don't look,
there's,
this is a real problem with the commission for presidential debates,
real PR problem with the fact that it's,
when it gets down to the big crunch time,
the commission for presidential debates is a privately funded institution.
It's not as simple as like everyone who's running for president gets an equal
say and we have all these qualified candidates and we're just going to figure
out whose the right guy for the job.
It takes a shit load of money to get to the point where you can actually run for
debate when you actually can get up there and actually have your opinion and
broadcast it to the world.
There's a lot of fucking hoops you have to jump through probably rightly so,
but there's some value in that,
but I think that as time moves on and the medium of the Internet becomes more
and more powerful,
most likely that will be less of a factor.
Having Anderson Cooper was goofy glasses,
asking questions about whether or not it's okay to be a conscientious objector
and still run for president,
which is one of the things that apparently he has Bernie Sanders.
I thought it was fascinating.
Well,
I got in trouble,
black lives matter or do all lives matter that that one was like,
okay,
well that's it.
Bernie said,
well,
fucking of course all lives matter,
but black on loaded question.
Two question answer.
They should say.
That's a loaded question and I'm not going to answer it.
Of course.
All lives matter.
I understand the movement and I think a,
B and c about,
yes,
I agree with you.
That's,
that's the right way to say it,
but he said black lives matter because that's the progressive left wing thing to
say because you're not going to get shit from white people about it,
but you'll get a lot of Brownie points from buying crap from Shaun king who was
a white guy about it.
Shaun king is a white guy that was getting out of that feminist film festival
for saying he was white.
They have rubber Titone,
tranny menstruating,
Jesus Christ.
I saw that.
I've got like it hasn't buff.
I find it funny,
but they're triggered by me saying Sean King is white.
That was one of my favorite videos of yours.
That was a really that and the Lena Dunham video,
but the that video particularly of you with the feminist because first of all
you being very reasonable and they got upset right away.
Like they were getting upset like you were.
You weren't being aggressive,
you weren't being rude,
you were asking like really pretty reasonable questions and you know they're
like disclosure.
I was being a disturber like I don't deny that.
Selectively edited anything you've ever watched his edited,
well,
what are you going to do?
Put All fucking three hours of whatever the fuck you were there.
Time like James O'keefe for Andrew Breitbart of the planned parenthood videos do
because they're journalists.
What I do is entertainment,
but they'll actually put up the full footage.
See,
I don't know what the fuck those planned parenthood.
I didn't.
I watched part of it and I was like,
is this real?
Like what's going on with this?
Are these people really talking like this about parts footage?
You can watch three,
four hours and the big thing he attack you and Carly Fiorina for talking about
it.
They go,
well,
it didn't really happen in a video.
Listen,
she has 30 seconds.
She's talking about pieces in the video that you can see and she sets it in a
narrative that she can answer in 30 seconds and they go,
well that all those things didn't happen in that timeline in a video.
Well,
educate me because were they or were they not saying that we can get you in
contact fetuses and then we were selling fetus parts.
Yeah,
so they were right.
So they don't think anybody's saying that it's a hoax.
Well why did they say the same thing?
You know with with a Andrew Breitbart,
the acorn scandal.
Well let's not get into that,
but we know it's important.
They attack the Messenger.
That's what they do.
ACORNS.
Scandal was pretty fucking clear.
They were,
they were literally giving people advice on how to sell it to the exact same
detention,
the exact same thing.
They said it's dishonest.
These are selectively edited.
And their final argument was when James O'keefe appear,
and I'm a,
I'm not a journalist,
so I just make it clear like that's why I don't release full.
It's designed to be funny.
It's more in line with the daily show.
Then something at Fox News or CNN.
Um,
James O'keefe went on Fox and friends in a pimp jacket,
like promoting the videos.
And their argument was he didn't go in dressed like a pimp and her dress that
they said they were pimps and prostitutes,
but they didn't dress like that.
How do you tell me I've pinned for a prostitute tresses cause I bet you're
wrong.
And the black lives matter,
people get mad at me.
Listen man,
dress like Ben Carson.
I was in drag,
I was in Vegas once and I was with a couple of my buddies and we were at this
bar and a,
it was a UFC diet.
Uh,
it was,
uh,
the,
the night of the way ends.
So we went to the winds and we were at the bar and there was this girl who
looked like a fucking executive at a fortune 500 company.
I mean,
she had a respectable business dress on,
she had nice clothes on,
a nice purse and she was talking to me and all my friends and I was like,
something is fucking going on here.
And then I'll,
I don't know what it was,
but my friends were hitting on her and all this and she was just a little too
receptive.
And I said,
so I,
I,
it was just,
my friends were ugly.
It was his,
I say,
you have low confidence in your friends as well.
They're savages.
Okay.
You know,
I mean,
maybe she just wants a gorilla fucked by a bunch of a bunch of savages,
but,
um,
but I was like,
something's going on here.
So I go,
um,
how much is all this going to cost everybody?
And she goes,
well,
it depends how many guys.
And they all went,
yeah.
And I go,
And then they went,
how'd you know?
And I go,
well,
I'm,
I'm guessing some insincerity.
She's working,
you're working right?
And she goes,
yeah,
I'm working,
you know,
and I go,
okay.
And so,
and then they were like,
damn,
yeah,
I go,
you thought she liked you?
And then everybody starts laughing.
I go,
well,
if you look at her,
she looks like she could be an executive for like a Mandalay bay.
Like she could be there.
Like is everybody enjoying their stay here at Mandalay bay?
Anybody want their cock suck for $1,000?
I mean it was like you run the pick up on that growing up in Montreal like I did
really well.
I mean it's everywhere.
But how do they dress?
Well,
I mean you just look when someone approaches,
you know,
I can't tell how they dress.
I about my pimps or prostitutes.
I'm saying the guy went out and a giant feathered purple coat and a fedora on
the show.
And again,
as a gag,
right?
It's like pimps up hoes down.
Right,
right.
And so the lab do that in the acorn video.
So this is misleading.
Okay.
So what is,
what is the argument against the planned parenthood video?
What are they saying?
That they're doing something that's illegal in selling baby parts?
That's,
but what is the argument against the video?
I'm saying when people,
so they said,
hey,
selectively edited it and that it didn't appear in the video.
And then when the full video footage was released,
the arguments that I saw was,
well,
no one's going to watch 12 hours of footage.
It's kind of,
I mean that happened to me.
If you want to get to the truth or something that's really important.
Right.
Do you have it?
That's the whole point.
So if you selectively edit it,
they say you edited it.
If you put up the full footage of like,
well you're hiding behind the fact that you know,
no one's going to watch that.
Okay.
But if someone does watch the full 12 hours,
they'll find it.
Is it,
does it appear like it did in the edited video?
Cause I watched the edited video and I thought like Whoa,
this is kind of crazy.
They're talking about it.
Like how did she describe it as like line items?
Yes.
And I was like fuck man,
that seems like really in human.
You're talking about feed his parts and that they can adjust their process in
order to get more intact video.
And then the other really fucking disturbing thing about the video was when they
reach into the pile of baby parts and their arms and they're,
they're literally point,
you see baby arms like,
and I'm pro choice.
I think you should be able to do whatever the fuck you want up to a point.
And I think it's one of those things in life that there is a gray area and I
think I'm pro choice.
If it's a bunch of cells,
I'm pro choice if it's,
you know,
a cluster of cells the size of a walnut.
But I think once it,
once it becomes in fucking human being,
like you're looking at a little tiny human beings inside someone's body.
I don't know what the call is.
I don't know what the legislation is.
They want to have abortions up to 22 weeks.
What does 22 weeks?
Four eight to Jesus.
Yeah,
that's Wendy Davis.
Uh,
and also if that's what they're pushing for and they want it to be,
you know,
and they want it to be taxpayer funded.
That's the deal that people have a problem with.
You know there you have some people who are pro life on principle and then you
have some people who say,
I still should never have to pay for an abortion and you should never be able to
force an employer to pay for the board low 42 weeks,
20 to 22 weeks.
Jesus Christ.
That's kind of me of path.
Three months.
That's what they want.
Legally.
Three months is weird because it's like it can't,
it's not viable outside of the womb,
but when you look at it,
it looks like a fetus put said,
see that's the thing that the left has a real issue with because they don't
want,
there's,
there's no open discussion,
there's no objectivity.
There's no,
when it comes to this like you are either my vagina.
Exactly.
It's either like you are pro choice or you are some fucking barbarian who's
prolife and you want to fuck with people's bodies and you want to stand outside
of abortion clinics with signs and show show aborted fetuses.
But I'm not saying that I am.
I am pro choice.
I think you should be able,
I'm not the person to tell you what you can or can't do with your body,
but what we're looking at is a baby.
Well it's,
yeah,
what it is,
it comes down to the irony of the left saying the right is anti-science and you
have well known atheist,
even like Christopher Hitchens and Dawkins isn't prolife,
but he kind of slipped up where they admitted that it was ending a life.
Chris Richards is like,
I think absolutely.
Undoubtedly it's a life.
And he walked people through it and then of course he became hated by the left
and a bigot and a racist.
So people who claim that the writer anti-science when it comes to abortion,
they want abortions past a point where there is no doubt that scientifically,
um,
that is much more than a cluster of cells.
I got into it with this comedian online from England because I'm Dawkins had
said something that like a,
a,
a fetus or an embryo is known is,
has just as much in common with a human being as a,
a pig embryo or something like that.
Or is no different than a pig embryo.
Actually forget how we worded it,
but I was like,
well that's just disingenuous because obviously a human embryo is going to
become a human if you don't snuff and out.
Right.
Pig Embryo is a fucking pig that this goes back to the same thing and political,
you know,
political correctness in standup or cultural Marxism,
it's the same thing.
It's not,
hey,
you can have a reasonable position.
You can argue being pro life and I can say,
okay,
I see where you're coming from.
It's you had a controller,
uterus.
But what I was going to say is that this guy started saying I was right wing.
He was like saying,
yeah,
you're right wing and this is,
I know I'm not and I'm pro choice.
I'm saying like right now that is going to be a baby.
You can't say that's the same as a fee as a pig because it's not.
And he was like,
it's no.
That was the other argument.
He was like,
it's no different than a seed.
I go,
it's not a seed I go cause the seed needs to be germinated.
A seed.
You need to put it in the ground and east he watered and then it sprouts and
then becomes a plant.
This is something that's going,
it's already growing.
This is a seed is the egg.
Okay?
That's the egg inside of a woman's body.
No one's saying you can't take eggs out of your body.
I'm not even saying you can't have abortions,
but let's be honest about what it is.
But it's,
it is a fetus or an embryo or whatever you want to call it.
Me,
there's a certain amount of weeks where it becomes scientifically considered a
fetus.
But you know,
I,
I'm not,
I'm not a right wing guy in a second,
but I don't like the distinctions man.
I don't like,
but the left sees you as that way.
That's the problem.
I don't think so.
I think I'm more people see me as being a liberal hippie then see me,
cause I smoked pot and I have tattoos and I encourage people to do drugs.
But I found out pro pro gay rights.
I'm pro gay marriage.
I'm pro choice.
I'm pro a lot of things that there are a lot of,
put it this way,
there are a lot of people in the Republican party who are that way.
Certainly the libertarian weeks,
certainly people who would pull the lever for that.
There is no one on the democratic platform,
no one who would even allow you that inch that you just express.
No one wanted to president.
They wouldn't even give you that time of day.
It's abortion on demand for free at any point.
That's their mantra and they can't stray from it and that's just that.
You know?
That's always where I try and speak with people.
Ah,
right wing douchebag.
Oh Gosh.
I just got echo and it was the word Douche bag was a trigger for the microphone.
Echo.
I didn't hear it.
I mean I didn't see your own head.
You have
douche bag.
It's a trigger that trigger your job itself.
You know,
I've been called a racist my whole,
anytime you've come out of the closet,
been banned for you all you are white
jokes.
I ended my set.
The reason Tony Comacho signed me was I ended my set on the n word er,
stuck the landing goodnight.
Everyone walked off and he was going,
okay,
I want to hear more.
Okay.
In all fairness,
Tony Camacho,
not,
not the best judge of standup.
I know.
Well,
no,
he's,
I don't want to see you.
You're a nice guy.
Well,
I slept on his couch and stuff for a very nice guy.
Yeah.
But my point is,
you know,
if you pull that out now,
it's,
I mean,
if I didn't have my own independent thing going,
you end someone's career.
Have you ever said the n word like Paula Deen?
The deposition was,
have you ever said the n word?
Anyone who's anyone who's,
who's,
who would sing along to a run DMC album would have to answer yes.
They didn't ask the context and that's where we are.
Anything run DMC,
they didn't,
I think you're thinking like Nwa maybe.
I mean,
it's in their name.
That's what Kanye does.
The end that douchebag.
But he's a brilliant Mc.
Yeah.
Okay.
He got a couple good songs.
He does.
Yeah.
All right.
Sorry,
what were you going to say?
You want to see some of that,
Tony?
Do I know what?
No,
no.
I'll tell you that later.
Tell you that off the Lewis.
A nice guy.
I liked Tony.
Yeah.
Oh,
it was always been a nice guy.
He's always been a nice guy.
My point is I was 17 and he,
you know,
brought,
would've said,
I want to hear more.
I'm not exactly sure if that,
that's the best way to end your sentence on.
The reason was,
the bit was,
and I've talked about it and I'll even do it here.
I talk about it and open about,
it was a,
it was a bit about French Canadians watching rap videos.
So you have these French Canadians who are trying to mimic urban accents from
the United States and to the point where you would have them use words they'd
seen in rap videos.
They didn't even grasp the meaning.
And so I did,
it was a whole bilingual set of using French words and merging English and white
kids using the n word and walking off.
And it was kind of a shock but really funny cause everyone had heard it.
And that's how I ended it.
That's like on the,
just for laughs too.
Speaking of the n word,
did you hear that Trevor Noah is a joke thieve cause it choked the flick
straight up the South African and the guy was out new,
the new host of the daily show did a show recently.
Um,
I forgot what it was for,
but it wasn't a broadcast show and he did an old Dave Chappelle bit for Dave
Chappelle bit,
I want to say from like the early two thousands,
like one of his early specials and I mean moved it around a little bit,
but it's the same fucking joke.
I mean verbatim.
Thank God you didn't get on stage at the comedy store,
get on stage with him at the comedy store.
Oh,
Trevor Noah,
why not?
Because they meant see,
oh the men's see you thing.
Well that's actually funny.
I will watch that.
And you know who I called,
I don't know if you're still with her,
was with Tony Camacho and I had a meeting with Stacy mark.
Yeah,
cause you mentioned her and I was like,
oh,
that must be my person.
She's still my age.
And she became my agent five minutes after that.
After that.
Then yeah,
because my agent at the time was the same age and has been seeing,
they wanted me to apologize to him.
Yeah,
I remember we're done.
How to list of going down.
This is what's weird.
I was nervous coming in here because no,
when I was at Fox News,
um,
I was there for four and a half years and I went on air,
you know,
for the first time I had never seen any of these people.
I don't,
I'd never had cable,
we didn't get Fox News in Montreal.
So I kind of went in and wasn't starstruck.
I've been watching you since I was like 10.
I mean,
they've fully as a national hero is a national treasure.
Newsradio UFC have been following for a long time.
So it's,
you know,
you have to make sure that you're still yourself in the face of someone who,
the one time I got really stressed up with Clint Eastwood and there's a certain
level of fame with which I'm no longer comfortable and I just made an ass of
myself.
Yeah.
That's a level like we,
yeah.
If I ever met Clint Eastwood,
I'd probably be a babbling fucking idiot too.
I was outlaw Josey Wales do it.
It's tough to get past that.
How do you say to him,
like,
I love doing every which way,
but loose.
What do you pick?
That's a good one.
It was a good one.
I don't know how they train them to say you're the shit dog and give him some
knuckles.
Well he said to me,
he turns around and now he kind of saw it was looking at him and I don't you
never want to be that kind of bothering you.
A I'm Clint and put out his hand like,
yeah,
he doesn't have to say that,
but he does.
Yeah.
He kind of,
I guess a lot of those really,
really famous guys,
they kind of have to do that because they don't want to assume that you know who
they are,
even though they do know that you know who they are.
So it's kind of like a common courtesy thing to ask your name instead of say,
what's your name?
Nice to meet you buddy.
Like you know who I am,
bitch.
Right.
You know what you do,
Steve,
Steve Crowder,
or nice to meet you.
You want to hear funny clean switch story.
Yes.
Okay.
So this is true.
They have to do with the Obama sit down thing.
Well,
look at this kind of thing with uh,
conservatives in the entertainment industry.
So it's very small and closed circuit and everyone,
it's small enough that people introduce themselves.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
I'm just doing kind of a comedian,
writer the La Fox News.
Uh,
Hey,
I'm so,
and Sel director and Clint Eastwood,
everyone knows he's there,
stands up and he goes,
hi,
I'm Clint former mayor of Carmel.
It's true.
It's not,
it's not untrue.
And if you want to be a mayor of a place,
that's a spot that's a fucking beautiful place.
God,
you ever been to Carmel?
The closest event is like to Santa Barbara and I've been through it on the way
up.
You know,
you got to keep going.
Carmel is on the way up to,
uh,
it's,
it's right next to big Sur.
It's like maybe half hour from big Sur.
Fuck,
it's beautiful up there.
That might be one of the most beautiful spots in this country.
Have you ever been in northern Michigan?
Yeah,
I've been in northern Michigan,
north of traverse city.
Um,
I've been old Yvette.
You know where all of that is now.
You've got to,
I mean,
it's been actually rated most beautiful area in the country for a few years.
Really?
Yeah.
Leland.
All County.
So it's like a,
it looks like the Mediterranean,
you know,
vineyards rolling down to water.
That's crystal clear.
No sharks,
a little bit of land price.
Um,
and it's just gorgeous up there.
Yeah,
there's some,
well,
there's some beautiful spots in this country obviously,
but when I was saying is that Carmel is,
it's a really unusual area.
There's not a lot of people there.
It's like,
it's like the land it like there's the water and then it doesn't go in that
deep,
you know,
the deep into the,
into the mainland.
It's his fucking stunning,
stunning countryside and beautiful views of the ocean.
Well,
that's where they did play misty for me.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
He's with beats the hell out of that broad.
He's probably been going up there for a long time.
That's what he just beats the hell out of her.
You can't do that anymore.
And we're watching it for the first time like,
oh,
this is pretty good.
And he just comes in the hell you want.
Just starts wailing on it.
I'm like,
oh my God.
You're like dirty Harry films.
He's just punching some prostitute with an Afro and you're like,
you can't like blowing them away with his 44 magnum.
You can't do any of that stuff anymore.
You couldn't make blazing saddles.
Super hard to punch women on movies.
Like that woman would have to be like a demon or something like that.
And even then,
even then,
I don't know,
I don't want to sit,
I'd say it's a representation of the patriarchal society.
That's right.
Like Mad Max.
Did you see that?
Everyone the remittance.
It wasn't bad.
It was bizarre,
but it was like a,
all these were saying it's,
it's pro feminist message cause it's Charlise thrown kicks ass.
And
then the feminist had actually,
it's not because the real leader is a guy and it's patriarchy and all these
Tumblr blog and it was like nothing can be gay guy.
Who,
what's his face?
Tom?
A what?
The fucks.
I'm hardy.
Tom Hardy?
No,
not Tom Hardy.
There's like an old gray haired guy who was like a leader.
I don't think Tom Hardy's guy.
He should.
Sean's reporter who asked him,
he said,
oh you're asking me about sexuality and it was like,
just go away.
It's not interesting.
Yeah,
that's what you're saying when you're gay.
Yeah.
I know.
My rule is if a woman claim she's bisexual,
like a teenager,
she's trying to be cool.
If the guy says that he's gay.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Right.
I've never met a bike guy who wasn't gay.
Yeah,
me neither.
Yeah.
I always say there's two types of dudes.
There's gay dudes and then there's really gullible,
straight dudes who get talked into blowing crafty gay dudes like Bowie McJagger.
We don't really want to do that.
David Bowie and,
Oh,
Jack All we met one person who's bullied Mick Jagger.
Yeah.
Fuck that.
Stand up and one of the top votes and Garfunkel emerging names.
That's fine.
Although that night they got it on,
they too became once I might've made that up about Tom Hardy.
No,
I think he talked about experimenting at one point,
but now all these guy,
are you a scientist?
We suck in the deck with a lab coat on a beaker in your hand.
What are you doing?
That's not for some reason I'm picturing beaker from the muppets game,
but back in the 70s and the 60s I think more people did experiment that might
not even be gay because there were,
they were breaking down so many bizarre boundaries and there was so much
restriction on behavior from the McCarthy era in the 1950s and the way people
behaved,
it was all of a sudden everyone's doing acid and they're free love.
And I think there was a lot of Dick suck in there that people want.
I shouldn't have done that.
Like they legitimately weren't gay but did some gay shit.
That's,
I'm a little,
I know I'm not a historian.
We were getting off the realm of,
of something that we can prove.
It works like Lavar Burton,
you don't have to take my word for it as you were Barb Burton gang.
No,
but I mean you were watching it and reading rainbow.
Do you think when he puts those things on is just glued inside there?
Maybe that's why.
Where's that kaleidoscope and Marvin,
hey,
we're looking at,
but
the big kaleidoscope,
remember reading rainbow and you'd always be like,
you know this book,
you talk about it and a little Polo and his is Burger King,
kids' club haircut.
And he's like,
but you don't have to take my word for it.
And it's like,
okay,
so we're not taking your word for it.
We should take the word of a bunch of six year olds,
this book.
Because I was like,
how have a little respect you have for your own opinion?
Lavar well I think just being humble,
right?
Maybe you know,
which is generally not a quality found in the gay community.
No,
I don't know.
They're dramatic.
They have a flair for the dramatic,
they do have a flair for the dramatic.
That's one of the cool qualities about them.
Oh,
it's hilarious guy in like a disaster.
Like a fire drill.
It's funny,
I've never seen a gay guy in a disaster.
I have a guy,
actually I was talking to my brother about it,
famous actor my brother works with and um,
he has like,
you know the earth,
an earthquake kit and it's,
do you have that in your trunk anymore?
Like an emergency kit?
Because he had that when he was here for the big earthquakes and he was in some
area where it was like really gay and he just said it was so funny.
They were just running around in the streets
and he's like super liberal,
you know,
further to left and either of us and tolerant.
He was just like,
it was just really a trip to see.
Well Milo,
you think he's going to be your rock when that goes down?
No,
no,
no.
He'll fall apart.
I don't know if he'll fall apart,
but he's running into the arms of another.
There's,
yeah,
I'm just going to be some issues there for sure.
But you know,
that's just not,
his wheelhouse isn't his wheelhouse.
Isn't fucking toughening up,
you know,
I don't know.
And fucking riding it out,
riding the storm out.
That's the negative.
I'm a little offended.
It is a negative stereotype,
but the femininity of the gay male,
it's very funny and it's okay to like I talked well that was at the same at
Seapak.
It was like this political action committee.
That's where Huffington Post's said,
I yelled the n word and I didn't.
And they said,
I joke about raping Ashley Judd and I didn't wait.
What was that?
Why did they say that was the fact check?
Stand up.
This is a Huffington post and that's why when we were talking you were doing
standup.
Yeah.
That was emceeing a political action conference.
Right.
I was just doing some bits and uh,
one of them wasn't a private room.
It was like a blogging awards ceremony and we had a rap video,
Mister America,
we were dressed up as Thomas Jefferson and George Washington.
And one of the jokes in the video,
you know,
it's not something you put on your resume,
but it was a bringing back knickers.
It's a rap song or record stops.
And I'm like,
no,
I can,
I can say knickers because I wear knickers and we actually have black producers.
Like,
oh,
okay.
You know,
gives us a thumbs up,
like put paths for knickers.
So I'm fine if I've been in post when I say,
okay,
they made a joke that's risque and you know,
but they just said,
Steven Crowder yells and word to Jesus Christ or Ashley makes rape joke about
Ashley Judd and um,
I'm sorry to interrupt.
Go ahead.
No,
no,
go ahead.
But that's what,
when you sent me them as a source,
I'm going,
you're sending it,
you know,
today's so long is tomorrow's Huffpo.
They are not the friend of standup comics.
No.
They want to destroy the voice of anyone who doesn't agree with them.
And that's a lot of standup comedians now.
And that's what's problematic.
Well,
what I've said about these people,
and I'll continue to say it,
I don't believe they're actually progressive's.
What I think they're doing is they're mining the world of ideas and they're
looking for things that they can attack.
I don't think they really want to attack it because it makes sense.
I think they're,
they're,
they're mining the world of ideas for the moral high ground and they're looking
to find things that they can be aggressive about and go after.
And it gives them a license to be really shitty to people.
Like they treat you,
treat someone,
you know,
you paint them as subhuman,
you can treat them subhuman.
Also,
it's really important if you really want to be a progressive person,
you really want love and acceptance in the world.
It's really important to not be a fucking asshole.
And there's a lot of these people like here's something I'm,
I'm a hunter.
Okay.
And so when I,
when I hunt,
I sometimes put pictures of these fucking animals online.
And one of the reasons why you do it,
I do it for a bunch of reasons.
One,
to see the reaction to the last one I did,
I did as a tribute to my friend Cameron Hanes.
Cause I,
I shot an elk with a bow and Arrow and he taught me how to do it.
It's hard to do the fucking nasty.
His people,
the meanest shit was vegans.
Sure.
Dog they were saying.
So I didn't read that.
But they're vegans.
Unsure dog.
Oh,
why do you reach your dog?
I actually,
that's how you want to know how far back it goes.
I had an account before the message boards,
I think even existed because I was watching the highlight videos because we
couldn't afford the pay per view.
So when I hear beautiful day from you too,
I still think of Sakuraba light kicking Henzel Gracie and it's beautiful
trigger.
But yeah,
you were all over.
Sure.
Doug,
they hate you.
That's fine.
But their animals.
Well,
meanwhile,
how many of those fucking dummies eat meat?
How many of those dummies have cats?
That's my favorite one.
People who have cats.
You buy cat food for your cat.
Guess what?
You're a fucking killer,
right?
Because they're not getting that shit from a cat food tree.
Okay.
They're grinding up animals that live a horrible life to live in cages and
they're sucking them out of those cages,
killing them in a ruthless cost effective manner and stuffing them into a can.
So you're a little fucking tabby Conine cause you still have to have a cat.
Yeah,
I like cats.
I know I haven't done,
I have two cats.
I have dogs too.
I'm a giant dog.
But,
but my point is that some of the meanest,
nastiest shit was being said by Vegans,
and I think that they have this green light to be a cunt.
And I think there's a lot of people that,
that what they do is they find areas where they have,
they feel like they have the green light,
you know,
they have,
there's a subject,
there's a,
an an issue that's come up and they feel like all these fucking people that went
after that Lion Guy,
like I'm not saying you should go to Africa and he killed a lion,
but I don't want to go to African killed.
I don't want to kill anything.
I'm not going to eat.
But that fucking guy did everything by the book,
by the way.
They all show the line with a name was his mistake.
Well,
here's my favorite part of it,
not just the protest and everybody's standing outside of his fucking clinic and
ruining his business.
Right.
My favorite part was they were worried about his brother,
the brother,
the lions,
Cecil's brother was,
what the fuck was his name?
I forget the brother's name,
but Cecil had a brother and the brother was also killed and everybody was
freaking out.
Oh my God.
And then they found that it wasn't the brother that was just another line and
everyone was relieved.
Hard to tell them.
It's hard to know.
Name fucking lion.
So if the line doesn't have a name,
that line ain't shit.
He's riding [inaudible] coattails.
You read the letter from the guy from Zimbabwe.
You see the numbers of how many people get killed by lions,
like 256 years or the ghost in the darkness.
Yes,
I did.
That's a nightmare.
Great movie since about Kimra when he was young.
It's sleek and sexy.
I know Michael Douglas was in that movie too.
I think Al Roker is val Kilmer and a fat suit.
We haven't seen Val Kilmer slimmed down considerably from that meme.
Have you seen it?
You've seen the bank?
I used to be Batman.
He's got this Dallas,
Joel Schumacher.
Joel [inaudible].
Both batch.
Yeah.
He was a director.
Remember when Val Kilmer was there was a good Batman though.
I thought he was good.
That's one of those songs.
I went back and watched and I was like Batman and Robin was bad.
That was really bad.
But Batman forever was that still.
And I went back and watched it and it,
I'm like,
I wish I would've just,
who was Robin?
Uh,
Chris O'donnell.
Oh,
that's whatever happened to that guy.
Uh,
he,
I think he has some show.
Alicia.
Alicia Silverstone was Batgirl too.
And then she's like a Vegan Peta person know.
Oh,
wasn't it?
He Crystal Donna with ll cool j and some crime show.
Oh Christ.
Even talking about that just dropped Iq.
Oh,
whew.
I was in a film Renny Harlin directed and he liked it.
All those things he's made of milk.
Yeah.
There he goes.
Hey guys.
Remember when I was that man,
I don't,
you know what's weird is I don't know how you let it get that far by Marlon
Brando.
You ever see on the waterfront and then see the last days,
the last days of Marlin Brando,
he's very off rated as an actor.
I wasn't holding your fan of James Dean and Marlon Brando was a different time.
But if you go to on the waterfront,
compare it to anything anybody else was doing.
No,
I disagree.
If you look at me.
Yeah,
the perfect scene is James Dean in rebel without a cause.
Um,
and it's so bizarre because he was very,
he was kind of like one of the first naturalists,
you know,
just wondered.
It was very,
if you look the way he spoke,
it was pretty natural,
but everyone else in the scene was still,
you know,
so he's like,
Oh mom,
you're tearing me apart.
Leave me alone.
Well,
that's a fine way to behave.
Young man.
I got that from his mother.
See?
And then you're going to James and he's sitting there talking and he's like,
and you're like,
this is real.
So you can just see when that transition happened.
And,
uh,
I think James Dean when he was alive,
didn't get the respect Brando did.
Hm.
I Dunno,
I didn't really pay attention to who got respect.
All right.
But I thought Brandon was pretty good.
And on the waterfront,
especially in comparison to the rest of the era.
You want to talk gay?
Um,
James Deane?
No,
no.
Well yeah,
but I mean the outfit,
uh,
the wild one with Marlon Brando,
the little leather and mailman hat and the handkerchief,
well you know,
when that became gay,
there'll became Jang.
Judas priest came around.
Right?
That's when it became gay.
Cause Rob Halford's gay as fuck.
Well they started everybody dressing guy.
They didn't even know they were dressing gay.
They just want her to be like Judas priest.
Do you think Marlon Brando would have dressed that way if he knew that was
coming down the pike?
I don't know.
Yeah.
I mean that's gotta be tough cause you're a sex symbol on your Marlin Brando and
then like this is going to become the iconic,
you know,
Mister slave outfit.
Yeah.
But Marlon Brando clearly didn't give a fuck about anything.
He didn't give a fuck about the way he looked.
He didn't give a fuck about his health.
I mean,
he was crazy towards the end of his life.
he was completely out of his mind.
Yeah.
I don't think it really mattered to him.
He wasn't the same rider.
I don't think that James Dean was on a motorcycle really from to understand
James Deane was pretty good.
Well,
I actually got to sit in,
you know,
there were only like something like 14 cars that James Deane,
spider,
Ferrari,
whatever.
It doesn't,
I don't know a lot about cars.
What it is,
Porsche?
Was it a Porsche?
The one that killed him?
Okay.
Really,
really low.
We'll actually,
what's funny is I bought my car,
it was a 2003 tourists,
but it was in the back of this car shop in Dallas where this guy has done like
George Bushes car.
He just decks him out and he was just this old guy who was selling his old car
and a,
they showed me that it was like some absurd I want,
I could be wrong with a million,
$2 million.
They said James Dean's was lot 13 or 14,
and this was like 11 or 12 and it was one of those exact cars.
And I just looked at it,
I'm like,
it's like a go cart.
You're so low to the ground that's gotta be tough to control.
And I mean it's actually easier to control because it's low to ground and it's
very lightweight.
Those are pretty easy to control for the time.
But if you compare that to like a Boxster today,
like a Porsche Boxster,
it's a boxer's way more competent car.
They just,
but those cars were a hundred percent mechanical.
And when you're,
when you're buying a car today like that,
like a boxer,
which is small,
you're dealing with all sorts of traction,
controls,
stability management,
there's all sorts of behind the scenes,
computer aided shit going on.
Uh,
a antilock braking systems is all sorts of stuff that's happening behind the
scenes.
I don't,
I just know when I saw it,
it was one of those things where that's a perfect example.
Kind of.
It was my dad explained some things to me this way as a kid,
right?
I saw that car,
I don't know a lot about cars at all.
I mean it was buying a tourists and I was like,
oh,
okay,
that's pretty cool.
He told me,
so he told me the exact same truth that he could have told you,
but if you'd have seen that car,
you probably,
oh my God,
want to look in and be really interested in it.
We both saw the same car.
We both experienced the same thing,
but it's an entirely different experience.
Right.
And that's just kinda the way the human condition,
which I just find sort of fast like to me,
I was like,
oh,
okay,
that's pretty cool.
Let me go back.
You don't know.
I mean if you showed me like an old golf club or something like that,
I wouldn't do shit about it.
But if you show me like an old pool cue,
like a ballot Boucher from like 1965 I'd be like,
ah.
Right.
You know,
just I know pool cues,
people stand,
you don't get Jujitsu.
Talk to him about it.
And he was like,
all right,
you were a little cotton belt and you're like,
no,
you know,
that's one of my main things that I have to do when fights go to the ground is
explained all the,
like if I was doing commentary and it was only black belts listening,
I w my commentary would be infinitely shorter.
Right.
Cause uh,
you know,
everybody would know kind of what's going on,
you know triangle setups.
I mean,
you'd be going like,
like when we do these fight companion podcasts,
we do them like sometimes doing with Eddie Bravo and when we're watching
situations we're talking about like some guy going for is,
oh shit,
he's go for the arm bar.
Oh yeah.
Like we know,
I don't have to say what he's got to do now.
He's got to be careful of the left arm.
If he gets left arm past a certain position,
then it's now he's not in danger because it's past the elbow.
Right.
So there's a whole,
when I'm trying to do,
when I'm doing commentary for the UFC,
when the fights go to the ground is help people that I know are watching this to
just see a jumble of bodies.
Yeah.
Well even sport Jujitsu for people who do Jujitsu is not very entertaining,
especially with the g with the gates.
Very robbed them.
It's a real problem because it's kind of boring as fuck.
Do you think it's gotten to the point?
My Dad and I were talking,
I mean my dad is sometimes purple belt and he,
um,
that's pretty cool.
He's 55.
He started in his fifties.
That's awesome.
And he actually hasn't had a point scored against him.
Really.
Your big guy.
He's probably a giant,
Huh?
Yeah.
Well he played hockey at u of m.
He's a real athlete and he stayed in shape.
So we actually,
ah,
I could bring up at,
I'll show you a video afterwards,
but,
so he's competed in all the way through blue to get his purple.
Not even had a point scored against him.
Wow.
And um,
his thing though is very strong takedowns top control pass.
And,
uh,
in practice he'll roll with guys who are doing the reverse della Hiva and all
this stuff.
And my dad and I believe,
and I don't know if you think as somebody to taekwondo taekwondo at one point
where there were some combat relevance and then when you get to the Olympics,
it's really not anymore.
I feel like sport Jujitsu was gone in that direction where you have a guy who
can be the best in the world and a one 25 division with a guy who would get his
ass kicked by a hockey player in a street fight.
And to me,
what you sort of lost shot of the hockey player weight 225 pounds.
A hockey player getting started at 200 is my point.
My Dad,
when he got started,
he would get look gay over their head because that was the hockey thing.
You can do that and you can do so I can't you do that.
I think gays are stupid.
I mean if you can take the collar,
if you can take someone's fucking the bottom of the jacket and wrap it all the
way around.
His neck.
Why can't you pull it over the head?
Stupid.
I mean,
and that's the thing is,
is is it's,
it's a weird situation you're getting into it and it's no longer really combat
relevant.
And we have a lot of guys who are,
you know,
the crossfit thing and all this ridiculous sort of strength training has come
into it and they're just,
they never get strong am going,
you know,
like the crossfit thing,
they don't get strong.
What do you mean no cross?
Well you should have mark Rippetoe on.
He'll,
he'll talk about that.
I mean with,
with strength training,
you need linear progression.
That's measurable.
When you're starting guy like you,
right?
You can do anything now and you're going to,
cause you have a strength base.
Someone who's never lifted heavyweights and added five pounds incrementally is
not going to get a lot out of battle ropes and snatches for five minutes.
He's not going to get a lot out of it.
He needs to increase his maximal strength.
So we have kids come in like,
no man,
I saw this.
This is what I'm doing.
It's a new strength thing.
They never get stronger then ever get bigger.
And I,
we started and my dad is to have this philosophy,
you start because you want to be a sovereign man.
You want to be able to defend yourself.
And if you're at a point where you,
you,
you're double guard pole and you reverse della Hiva and,
and you're no longer able to actually protect yourself.
I don't know.
I feel like it's lost.
I mean holy is,
Gracie is a good example.
You know,
he wouldn't do well in sport Jujitsu,
but he was big enough.
He was strong enough to get it done and protect himself.
And when altercation,
well the game has passed him by and a lot of ways,
but I think that there are a lot of guys in sport Jujitsu that would do great
like Cyborg,
you know?
Right now Michelle.
Yeah,
great.
that was a white belt.
Yeah.
Now he's a bad ass.
There's a lot of really great Jujitsu guys,
but I agree with you like 50 50 guard.
There's a lot of silly shit that that guys are doing that just doesn't seem like
it's also kind of boring to watch,
you know,
and a lot of ways.
But then there's like no g like Eddie Cummins,
guys like Gary,
Gary Tonin who are like super aggressive,
very,
you know,
overly aggressive.
There's a lot of guys,
Marcello Garcia,
very aggressive submission oriented attacking style.
So there's,
there's gonna be guys like in the taekwondo days that just play point style.
But there's a,
there was always guys back then they were terrifying because they would not guys
dead.
You know,
even during my taekwondo competition days,
I remember there's this guy from the Ivory Coast that everybody was terrified
of.
His name was Patrice remark because his style of attacking was so much different
than everybody else's.
Everybody else was playing this sort of,
not everybody,
but a lot of people playing this sort of point game.
And this fucking dude was this like shredded black guy from the Ivory Coast kick
through you from Africa.
She's in Africa.
Africa is fuck.
He could be a what guy from Africa that the South American accent from Africa.
Yeah,
that what did the,
it's like a Dutch thing,
right?
There were Dutch settlers that came to South Africa or South African almost
sounds like they're faking an Australian accent.
Like a bad comic.
Like I'm Australian.
Right?
You're like,
Eh,
it's not real.
It's like,
oh,
it's just South Africa.
Well,
that's when we saw the two collide on lethal weapon.
Remember Mel Gibson to o had at it with the pot died guide.
The bite died.
What did he call them?
It Kevin,
what is he saying?
This was like,
no,
it was down the line,
but they had to like,
he was like,
Danny Glover was a black guy and he had a bad name for black guy is too old for
that shit.
You know,
he is too old for that shit.
I just like when you go back and watch it and you realize that Mel Gibson is
crazy,
you go back and watch those and you can kind of see the flashes.
You're like,
oh yeah,
that makes sense.
But do you think that Mel Gibson got crazy or do you think you always was crazy?
No,
I think,
I mean
I've spoken actually with some people who worked in the passion of the Christ
and I think he got so much heat for that.
Um,
I mean you talk about sort of like social justice warriors.
He got so many people who went after him and I just don't think he was expecting
are used to that kind of pressure I think.
Have you ever heard of the voicemails?
Oh yeah.
To me that is the funniest thing I've ever heard in my life.
Well,
it's funny to me,
but it's sad because he's an old guy.
He's dating this Russian assassin,
you know,
and she's stealing has come and we're making babies and
as he's like off the wall,
angry,
right?
For people who haven't heard it,
shut up and blow married,
he starts yelling at my friend and I said,
okay,
listen,
listen.
And I cue it up.
I let people listen for context.
I go,
this is the funniest thing you'll ever hear.
And no one laughs except for me and my producer,
gay Jared,
where he's like,
you have no show.
You have no,
but I will give you one more chance.
And I don't know why.
I just find like anyone who's been through a breakup or you're like,
I want to tell her off but I want to make it work,
want to sell it.
I will give you one more chance.
And she goes,
I don't want another chance.
It just goes crazy and it to me it just like the pain.
Do I think it was horrible,
the things he said.
Yeah,
but anyone who's been in like one of those horrible breakups and you feel like
you're not being heard has felt that anger and then he tries to pull it back.
Oh,
we'll give you one more Jeannine's better friends.
Well Robert Downey's,
his best friend.
Really?
Yeah,
they're close friends.
Robert Downey Jr.
That's what he said.
He came out and introduced him at some award thing.
Interesting.
I wonder if Robert Downey junior hates the Jews as well.
I don't think he'll come out and say it because Mel Gibson,
you just get a couple of cocktails into him and apparently he just starts hating
Jews.
It's just,
oh well that's,
I don't think about the cocktail over,
make them hate.
No,
but that's what gets it out of them.
People that got him pulled over in Malibu,
the cops that pulled them over.
We're saying he's just fucking spout,
not all this fucking anti stuff called the one cop sugar tits.
I'll think of kite.
I don't know.
I don't know why I find it really funny.
I know it's terrible and people will us up against me.
It's an example of being racist.
I just find that pain funny because everyone's felt it and then he tries to pull
it back.
Oh,
give me one watch
in my head.
It is funny because my,
the pain of everything you just said,
you hope she gets raped by a pack of and word.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot about that part.
It's a pack of wild and words,
right?
Wasn't it like they're just roaming through like that's what they do.
Yeah,
like,
like fucking lions.
And then,
but you know what though?
The crazy thing is you don't know that he hates black people.
No,
he could have like,
you know,
I'm Michael Richards.
Well,
you sit in those movies with Danny Glover.
They seem to get along wonderfully.
And that's one thing I've talked about with people.
People go,
oh,
you're going to have a black friend.
Now here's,
here's the thing.
If you have a lot of black friends,
my black friends over for dinner,
do I,
aside from Tony Camacho?
Yes.
Uh,
yeah.
Plenty of black friends.
But those last time black,
I was over your house for dinner.
Probably been in,
why
you're coming back telling me about some black guy shot someone at the comedy
store and then you can put me on the hot seat and have a black guy home for
dinner.
Well,
I don't know what you're saying.
Was it grass fed?
Did you feed them grass fed grass?
I don't know otherwise.
I don't know.
I just like bring out the corn fed steak.
He's a negro.
I mean,
what do you think about it?
Bad steak.
You are all in the grass fed corn fed beef to really?
Yeah.
It's not bad.
It's fatty.
Sometimes it tastes delicious.
Nice corn fed.
Prime Rib.
I don't have the Joe Rogan salary.
So it's mostly corn fed.
Well his grasp it that much more expensive.
Oh my gosh.
It's so much more.
Some money.
Although I've been,
I've never hunted,
but I was,
my uncle in law has a cider mill up in northern Michigan and um,
all the deer just keep eating samples.
So he was like,
listen,
I have a permit.
Something absurd.
I don't know the number,
like to kill like five a month or something because they're just constantly
eating his apple so that you want to come up.
And I was like,
I mean,
I'm not a hunter,
but I could literally just sit there in a lawn chair with my three 57 take a
couple of them out while they're eating some Fujis and 57 yeah,
they changed the law.
You can hunt with handgun cartridges,
but you don't want to be seven out of a rifle.
Oh.
As ballistics that are higher than mid caliber rifle stuff.
Old Rifles,
just more accurate.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
But out of a six inch barrel handgun,
three of you,
seven,
you're actually gonna get really surprising bliss,
but you'd have to be really close.
They're going to eat a red delicious right in front of me.
I'll be in a lawn chair with I probably from me to you.
These things love the apples.
That's the point.
That close.
Yeah.
They just eat the apples.
They go nuts.
I'm P and all over the cider orchard property cause apparently it helps and you
just like,
listen,
you want to kill them.
I know a guy who will process and write down the road.
It's delicious meat.
Especially if they're eating animals.
I just don't know how to cut out the anus.
It's not hard.
It's,
it makes me nervous.
If you know how to operate a microphone,
you can figure that out.
I don't think I've done a stellar job of that today.
I'm not used to yet.
So not hard.
But um,
yeah,
gutting them.
It just,
you get used to,
it becomes normal.
You understand where to go and how to turn it around and well,
they've opened it up in Michigan because it's just a real problem for eating
everything.
We pulled it up the other day.
Um,
there was a number of the amount of driving accidents involving deer,
deer hit in Michigan and in more than 40,000 would it pull that up again,
Jamie?
I won't ride the motorcycle and the out there in any rural area with a deer,
it's insane.
I mean,
people who live in urban environments,
they get upset at hunting.
They don't understand.
You literally don't understand these animals.
I have vastly overpopulated to the point where they bring in hunters in suburban
Pennsylvania because they have no,
they have no limits.
You can shoot as many as you want all day long,
all year long.
And they,
they bring people in.
Just a bar.
A lot of parts of Pennsylvania.
Um,
I don't know specifically which counties,
but I know that these guys,
and I know that her bow hunters,
they fly them out to Pennsylvania and they film shows whether they're
essentially in these fucking people's yards and they have,
they set up tree stands and I'm not kidding you,
but it's a nice yard.
But suburban neighborhood,
nice houses.
It is,
it's a,
it's a home,
like that's got like several acres,
like two or three acres in there.
They have tree stands set up and they're just killing as many deer is.
Walk their way.
I can imagine.
Yeah.
The,
and they have to because the driving accidents are fucking crazy.
So many people hit them.
Yeah.
I just three 57 is my,
my guts.
Your gun of choice.
Why is that?
Sounds good.
Yeah.
It sounds like three 57 handgun out of a four inch barrel is going to have
better ballistics than any other caliber,
uh,
for self defense.
And the reason why is I have a giant bucket of 38 and giant bucket of 30 sevens
with Lever Action Rifles,
different handguns.
And my wife doesn't need to worry about what goes into where.
And I have a beautiful,
like almost collector's item,
an old three 57 Smith and Wesson.
It's an old one from where?
Smith and Western.
It's like an eight,
maybe like how long?
It's not that,
but it's before they have the,
um,
the internal lock and it's nickel plated.
It's just beautiful.
It's my favorite,
like the trigger on that thing.
It's just butter smooth.
Here's the number average of 134.
Dear vehicle crashes each day.
Holy Shit.
That's Michigan resulted in 1,329 injuries in eight deaths.
Wow.
Just kill those things.
Yeah.
While there their food,
you know,
that's the thing about them.
You know,
I've never been on any of that joke too out.
You should.
It's not,
it's not bad.
It's fun to do.
I don't think at all that they want to say that it's,
people don't want to say it's fun for some reason.
I don't understand that.
Like it's ethical and it's fun.
It is fun.
Why denied that?
It's fun.
The shift.
Productive.
Yeah.
It is definitely productive.
Certainly more productive than shooting at the range.
Well it's especially if you want to eat healthy meat that's natural and organic
and especially if you want to help control the population of these animals and
because there's only one of the way you're gonna bring in wolves.
When are you going to bring in mountain lions and have them run through the
streets of Pennsylvania?
Come on.
I mean you don't really have a lot of other options for controlling the
populations of these fucking animals.
We'd a bobcat in our yard and a hopper.
Our dog,
like when after that thing.
Cool looking.
They're cool.
They look weird.
You can't catch it,
but he would have messed it up.
I had one of those my ARD wants.
It was the weirdest thing.
I was like,
what is that fucking cat?
I have like the Wolverine Ghana thing that has like the tips of their ears are
like fucking weird looking.
I was like,
what is that?
Yeah,
it's very strange.
Look,
their back legs look longer than they should be.
Yeah.
It's a weird sort of,
it's a,
it's a weird sort of body dynamic,
but,
uh,
yeah,
our dog went nuts for it.
And if he,
if he'd have been able to catch it,
it would've killed him.
He would have killed it.
Yeah.
Well,
how big is your dog is a dog.
Oh,
okay.
That's a big fucking dog.
Yeah.
Well,
I think Ronda Rousey has one.
He's a little bigger and he was a rescue.
That's not,
that's nothing for perfect example of leftist and animal rights.
Like we have a rescue came to us with a broken leg,
balding Lyme disease.
You know,
look,
he wasn't the perfect dog.
We've basically brought him back to health.
I volunteered at shelters,
helped with them.
But you know what I also tell people,
if you have kids,
you probably shouldn't adopt a dog.
You probably should get it from a puppy and rage and know about that dog.
He's perfect for us.
He's a little bit racist.
I'm not going to lie.
I don't know.
And he's a white dog.
He's started by his racist.
You know,
it's funny.
He loves black men.
Uh,
women's towards black boys,
Black Pole,
like 12 year old black boys.
He just,
he just like,
he just little leery.
Ooh.
Specifically them and he's not aggressive so he just,
but you just see he wants to be pet by everyone.
He's the most friendly pack,
ranted dog,
younger black boys.
He's like,
wow.
And he's all white so that's all.
There are a lot of dogs that are fucking sketchy as hell around kids.
I had a friend who had a pit bull that was really sketchy around kids and it's
just,
he had never been around kids and kids to him looked like little animals.
Like you didn't understand what they were.
Well it's unstable.
Yeah.
Our dog actually hopper,
he's a,
if my wife and I argue at all or for ranting about our day,
like I have to be careful when I do the radio show.
He'll sit in the corner,
look in the corner and shake.
He gets upset,
he gets a bit,
it'll actually shake.
Oh,
so like he was abused.
He just,
when we pulled out a musket for video,
but it like never before in front of him.
He pulled it out barking like crazy,
showing us to foaming at the mouth with the Moscow.
So we don't know.
You know you're 70 scene and you're,
if you're a kid and you're playing,
it's like the woman who had her face ripped off.
I had a female rescue dog that you,
if you raised your voice,
she would just drop to the ground and cower.
You couldn't say,
what are you doing over there?
Ooh,
right.
He just,
she had been beaten and the other dogs that I had from time,
they're puppies.
I'm like,
what the fuck's going on with her?
Yeah,
he's just Christ.
Do you know how this house works?
Exactly.
You have to.
Um,
but we actually tried to rescue another dog and a lady wouldn't give it to us
because she found out my politics and true still.
Oh,
come on.
I swear to you what come on really?
Dog's name is Mister Beg.
I wonder how he's probably a crazy cut.
What she is.
She was,
she was a super hippie and she was looking for a reason.
And so like it was this shelter where you have to go in for a whole weekend and
learn all these dogs.
So it was actually,
I ended up volunteering and this one dog,
everyone was scared of,
he was like an American bulldog mix,
so he's about 120 pounds called mister big and he would just fall at the mouth
and be barking up that,
you know,
at the,
um,
he recalled his fence.
Yeah.
But they all have their own individual runs in this one and you just go in.
He's just excited.
So no one wanted to take him out that he was just great.
And um,
what really got her mad was we had to watch like this dog training video,
how to learn dog body language.
And you had a little like writing comes in like an early nineties,
a VHS.
And I went out and she'd say,
what'd you think of the,
what'd you think of the source material?
I said,
you've got to love that early 90 saved by the bell font.
Right.
She like wrote something down and she was furious because you made fun of the
font.
I don't know.
I just know I didn't get your dog like that dog could have had a house.
We're happy with their dog,
but you know,
it breaks my heart to think of them.
But how do you know that it was about your politics?
That's what she said.
Well,
she said because when there was no valid reason,
um,
because we know the owner of that place,
she said,
uh,
well I just,
you know,
I get,
I get to choose who gets what dog and that's just,
he's just not the right dog for them.
I wouldn't give them any dog.
What she said,
Well,
how did she know that she like Google you and yeah.
Well I came in and the guy who owns it was a fan,
said I was like this multimillionaire who just kind of a fan and he,
I think he probably let her know or something and she was,
oh,
so he's a fan of yours,
but she works for him and she's not a fan,
but she gets the ultimate decision.
He's very hands off with that.
Yeah.
Wow.
But weird.
He's a great guy.
He's a great guy,
actually is this multimillionaire and uh,
people just hate him where we are.
And you just meet him and he's like,
he's made all of his money.
What's crazy,
and this is sort of something we don't tell kids.
I talk with people about this.
We said,
well,
what do you want to pay?
I'm going to be a firefighter now you need to ask him what kind of a lifestyle
do you want to live?
Because this guy's made all of his money off of Burger Patty machines,
machines and multimodal like,
no kid goes,
Alan,
I make Burger Patty machines.
But you know,
you say,
hey,
you want to never have a boss and have a bank account with tens of millions of
dollars and that feels pretty good.
Burger Patty machines.
Well this guy's already got the market cornered though.
Maybe tell him something else.
Yeah.
You know,
I don't know.
Hot Don machine.
How many more fucking people can make Burger Patty machines?
Imagine if you come along with a new one,
you know,
he'll fucking box out of the business.
He probably could listen,
it's the 1% kid saying,
I got this market cone.
It may be you need to make hot dog machines,
but you know,
it's a perfect example.
He's rich,
we're supposed to hate him and he's a great guy and he's been,
you know,
he runs this giant non killed dog and he's just like,
but everyone just hates him.
Okay,
you some people,
yeah,
you're supposed to hate wealthy folks that are famous or that are successful
are,
unless they're actors,
then you're not.
Well,
actors talk about the wealthiest 1% and you know,
they go out and they talk about the people,
but they don't care.
They are the 1% of course,
a lot of ways you're the one,
you're the top 1% of the top 1% of 1% well,
here's what's really crazy.
If you make more than $34,000 a year,
you're in the 1% of the world.
Yeah.
You know what,
your 1% in the United States,
what?
500,000 annual family income,
you know it's top 10% 150,000 annual household income.
Whoa.
So we're actually have it with video going up right now at the site today,
we're actually launching an ar 15 giveaway and we have a video on Bernie said,
yeah,
we're giving him away folks.
Sorry,
can I get you a show to play ar fifteens?
Yeah.
Did you believe in background checks?
Think yeah,
yeah,
we do all that and actually it's done through ar fifteen.com and they sell
custom.
Well of course you at 15 doing it legally,
you have to have back on shit.
But I'm going to have your politics.
Do you think that with our background checks?
Yes.
Right.
That's fine.
You don't have a problem with the gun show loophole.
What's that?
Is that what you're talking about?
The gun show loophole.
What?
Gun show loop.
Oh,
well that's it.
That is an interesting loophole.
You know,
you can sell guns to people.
People explaining the gun show loophole for people don't understand this.
You know,
they say with a background check at a gun show,
there's a loophole and you can get a gun without a background check.
Here's the thing.
I think it was Charles Cook who was one of those cable news networks.
Sorry,
I have to Burp.
Want to have to go ahead.
Go ahead.
I don't have a cough button here,
Leah.
It's quiet burp.
Yeah.
This show is real as fuck.
We don't,
we don't believe in,
we'll get them and actually we're going to probably put a cough button.
We're going to do that.
We do.
We decided that yet we didn't really decide.
We're thinking about putting a cop out in the next studio that helps me zero
right now.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Just talking to them.
My thing is with the gun issue,
what people don't,
it's about the hit,
the intrinsic right to self preservation.
So a good example is you don't have,
you asked me if I did stand up.
I don't do a ton of it anymore,
but I have one next week.
Um,
when I do any live performance now there has to be armed security and some kind
of a gate.
It's just the way it is.
Same thing with someone like Ann Coulter,
Miley Annapolis.
You don't just get to go up and do standup anymore,
but Milo does.
He shows up at slut walks.
Yeah,
I do that too.
But that's different from an announced show on a schedule where people can,
can show up to show that you're going to be there.
You have armed security always at all of your shows.
I do it.
Yeah.
Why is that?
Because it's crazy.
Death threats and I don't talk about it a lot cause you ever want me to a person
like Lena Dunham?
I got a death threat because I showed my nipple.
It's like legit when you question is,
well,
I'm going to do those videos and you're on cares watch list.
Do you have to be careful?
Well,
you did a video that was pretty fucking ballsy where you showed the actual
history of Muhammad as opposed to the history of Jesus.
Like the differences between the Christian religion,
the Islamic religion,
right.
It's pretty,
pretty ballsy.
And when you did that,
is that when,
what was before that?
That was a sequel.
That was the foreign challenge too.
And I remember this was before I was at Fox News.
I called Andrew Breitbart the first one,
and I put it up,
I go in this,
there's,
there's some,
there's some backlash.
Andrew,
can you help me?
He goes,
I'm going to get it to the online guy at fuck.
And he said,
when you're dead,
it's a story kid.
And he hung up the phone.
What?
That's what he says,
what he said.
Yeah,
that's right.
The second one.
But I mean even you as someone who doesn't subscribe to either faith,
you know,
my whole point is you can point to imperfect people.
Then any side of the spectrum,
but go to the founders.
And there's a huge difference with Muhammad.
So we actually showed,
um,
you know what,
a six year old,
nine year old girl looks like,
who was white was,
it's not the same as a 14 year olds,
which was normal.
Well you showed a girl that was actually older than his wife.
Yes.
Yeah,
yeah.
When you're on set,
when she showed,
I think so she was like 10 and actually her dad is really into Jitsu guy who
runs a school in Dallas is kind of fucked up when you,
you stop and think about the history of a lot of religious stories.
I mean if you go back and think about what was acceptable,
you know,
2000 years ago,
a thousand years ago,
1500 year,
whatever it was,
it's,
you're talking about a completely different era,
you know,
and that's one of the problems with enforcing a lot of religious scripture
today.
You know,
like this is many things that people do in the by.
My favorite is religious people that get tattoos.
And I'm like,
look,
if you're a Christian,
you get a tattoo.
You just,
you've got to read the whole book.
Okay.
Cause you're not supposed to get tattoos.
Well No,
they would say they would argue that Christ came to,
you know,
change the law to abolish loss.
They're not beholden to some of the dietary laws or the fabric laws.
Bacon.
Yeah,
exactly.
That fabric,
the fabric,
Lothian Abic laws,
two different types of cloth.
Do you understand why that exists?
Uh,
I would assume the fabric law has to do with the people that we're constructing.
The fabrics back then that they had like no gang wars between silk and cotton.
No,
no.
Kind of.
But what it was a big reason for that.
You have certain laws that were applicable to everyone,
like the 10 commandments and then you had laws that were designed to separate
the Jewish people.
That's like a team Jersey.
Cause everyone else is doing this.
So your beard is going to be this way.
Your fabrics going to be this way now.
So that's where brilliant theologians far smarter than myself.
I said,
well,
this is why these laws apply in.
These thoughts don't.
But my point is,
I don't have a problem with,
you know,
like Tom Cruise,
I haven't stood up when he would like,
he jumped on a couch.
I don't really care.
He's a little nutty.
Whatever.
Um,
was I have to do with religion?
Well,
Scientology and was going to sign it out,
but it's drinking on the couch.
Did you think that,
my point is,
a lot of people said,
you know,
Scientology's messed him up.
I don't have a problem with Scientology.
I don't have a problem with Buddhism.
Hinduism,
I don't,
there is one religion right now in this world.
One religion.
We're over 300 million people right now on earth.
Deserve that.
Believe that you deserve to die if you leave the Islamic faith.
They,
these are the people who will answer.
Yes.
When you say if someone converts from Islam,
do they deserve to be executed?
Yes.
Over 300 million people in the world right now.
So when you say it's like a small minority,
it's because you live this privileged life.
Ironically enough in the United States.
And you're not acknowledging the founder of the faith.
What is callings were and how every Islamically run country at.
It's not the same thing.
It's not the same as any other religion.
And that's what I was pointing to.
You can find hypocrites,
you can find crazy Scientologists.
You can find crazy Christians,
but don't look to Christians,
look to Christ.
And you may not like Christ.
You may think he's weird.
Don't look to Muslims because you have Muslim refugees now going into Germany,
Syrian refugees who want welfare dollars per cigarettes.
That's not Muslim.
Look to Mohammed.
Mohammed did kill Mohammed,
did call for the deaths of Christians and Jews.
Muhammad did screw with six,
maybe nine year old girl.
He beat her but only lightly.
So you couldn't see bruises if she was dressed up as a Ninja.
That's not hard to do.
These are different things and people need to acknowledge it.
And the left that labels me a racist that labels you right wing because you have
a different opinion and you go off the reservation all of a sudden just
completely ignores that and sort of accepts it as as cultural relativity.
Well,
you don't really understand the reason a woman needs four witnesses when she's
had the the crap rape dot of our.
We're going to ignore that and talk about some people here who are pro life
cause their hands are on your uterus and that's what bothers me.
Well,
I get bothered by any ideology that's rigid.
Anytime you have to subscribe to a bunch of rules,
you have to fast during a certain time of the year,
you have to wear a certain outfit.
The women can't drive.
They're not allowed to go to school like any,
anytime you have really rigid ideologies and then those ideologies,
you find out that they're ancient and they're established by a warlord.
I mean that's,
that's,
that is what Christianity,
that's the difference between Christianity and Islam.
Yeah.
Like Jesus was supposed to be a man of peace and Muhammad was supposed to be a
warlord.
That's,
well,
he helped fund office.
He wage wars,
he beheaded people.
He did all those things.
It's a fundamental difference in the ideology and it's,
it's,
it shows itself in the behavior of the people that are a part of the ideology in
their minds.
This is all,
it's all like guaranteed in the scripture.
It's all in there and their eyes,
what they're doing is all hollow,
all everything is,
you know.
Yeah.
Hello.
It's,
you know,
it's one of those things,
it's,
it's also a political ideology and legal prescription.
That's what people don't understand.
And they go after Ben Carson and say he's a bigot.
So He's black,
right?
All conservatives were racist.
And then when Clinton announced her nomination,
all conservatives became sexist.
So with Ben Carson,
he's not really racing.
What we'll see is a bigot because he said he thought that he would have a
problem with him.
Muslim president who supported the actual ideals of law in the Quran,
Sharia law.
And they ask him,
said,
well,
what parts,
what parts do you have a problem with?
And you know,
Ben Carson,
he goes,
it's not unreasonable at all.
It goes,
well,
you know,
I think that there are parts that are impossible to rectify with the
constitution.
Like,
uh,
you know,
the treatment of women,
the requirement of witnesses for a female rape,
the subjugation of all non Muslims,
the dimitude in the poll taxes,
which of course couldn't be allowed in the United States.
So I believe that we'd have to have a Muslim reject those precepts if they were
going to be,
oh my God,
he's an EMT.
Wasn't like that's a reasonable position.
It's a very reasonable position.
And that thing was a reasonable thing about the Nazis.
Entirely reasonable.
The term Islamophobia two is a very disingenuous term.
Like I,
that that term drives me nuts.
If you criticize Islam,
you're Islamophobia.
What does a phobia phobia is a fear.
You fear of irrational religions.
Yes.
I have a fear of those.
Well,
I'm also afraid of the moonies I'm afraid of,
I'm afraid of a lot of cults.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because I don't think anybody should be able to tell you how the fuck you should
think.
I think the,
the idea of having a government and having laws that are established by the
people,
for the people that make sense,
that give people equal freedom to give people equal say freedom of speech,
freedom of religion,
freedom to practice,
whatever you feel,
as long as it doesn't infringe upon the rights of other people.
I think all those things are great.
I think as soon as you have any sorts of ideologies that infringe upon those
things and the fact that progressive people,
which is really weird,
they'll shit on Christians all day long and have no problem with it,
but they leave it Islam alone and the reason why they leave Islam alone,
it's cause they don't want to get killed.
That's the reality as Lama phobic.
Exactly.
Well that's the real is not criticizing it.
Criticizing it is not as Lama phobia.
It's like it's just a legitimate criticism.
It's a ridiculous idea.
They're all ridiculous.
I think anytime you,
you've,
you buy into some rigid shit that was created way before people understood the
world the way before people understood science way before people understood the
distance between the earth and the sun,
the moon,
the rotation of the earth.
I mean,
think about all the shit that happened to Galileo when he tried to say that the
earth wasn't the center of the universe.
Right?
I mean that's all religion,
the inquisition,
it's all religion.
There's so many things that had been done,
horrible things in the name of the ideology.
One of the things just as much in the name of atheism,
of course Michael Shermer had a interesting piece on the differences between
Islam and other religions and it was all essentially say he was saying that it
was the one religion that didn't go through the enlightenment.
It all these other religions,
all these other religions,
they sort of morphed and adapted to the new information.
You know,
obviously some less than others and obviously some,
I mean,
when you see the fucking pope dressed up like a wizard and you got to go,
well obviously he's got some of that old crazy shit in his,
in his,
in his fucking war chest,
but he's,
he's this pope.
Is Bernie Sanders in a funny,
he is right?
He's an interesting one.
I think he's a,
I think he's a faker.
I think what they did is they found some guy and they go,
look,
this is,
we're going to keep this thing rolling,
right?
Yeah.
We'd like to have the gay bath house right above the Vatican,
you know?
I mean date they owned the largest gay bathhouse in Europe.
You know that,
right.
Do you know the whole story behind it?
Let's talk about Islam.
Why Not Catholic?
I will.
I am.
Well,
I was raised,
well,
that's also very different.
You know,
and one thing that,
you're right,
I just don't want to create a moral equivalency.
I think we can agree that pragmatically,
even if they have a gay bath house,
it's not the same as hundreds of millions of people who want you and I blown up.
No,
it's not.
I mean that's a difference in Catholicism.
Like first of all,
they,
you know,
there's,
there's no proselytizing.
They're trying to convert people.
They do obviously shield child molesters.
I mean that was one of the reasons why the,
the last pope had to step down and that guy,
the reason why the Vatican has so much,
that's why writing or I had to step down.
Oh yeah.
Do you know he's wanted for crimes against humanity.
They want to prosecute him for crimes against humanity.
That guy shielded child molesters.
The point where one of the guys he shielded went on to molest a hundred plus
deaf children.
I mean they,
they fucking sent him.
They would take that even here.
Oh it's cool.
How dare you.
How dare you,
how dare you sneak that one in.
Sorry.
But he was one of those guys and actively shielded people find a problem with
that.
And I've,
you know,
I think people toss religion under the same thing as people of faith.
And you know,
Islam doesn't really allow,
allow any sort of practice of faith or relationship when we want to call it
outside of their very specifically prescribed doctrine.
When you talk about [inaudible] specifically prescribed doctrines,
like how much of the Bible do you believe is real?
You know,
we want to get into each and every issue of the bylaw dudes coming back from the
dead and I can get into it here.
You know what I think,
here's what I think.
Here's what I think Joe and I,
to be fair and you might,
this might take a real turn where you might get angry,
but I hope you don't doubt it.
Um,
it's intellectual Poquito when you do that,
you need to have a Dinesh d'souza on or Lawrence Tisdale on,
cause you can say these things,
I'm not equipped for it.
I'm a blue belt.
I have,
I've,
I've looked at the swath of evidence and I've made up my mind.
But if you see this stuff is crazy,
this,
well,
I've made my decision and it's likely to change and I'm like that.
My faith has changed.
Has It?
Unless you fast.
Yeah.
I think certain parts of my face of changed,
but my point is until you have someone like that who's qualified to do it,
the same people who are going to be talking about,
sorry,
nine 11 being an inside job or whatever it is.
Someone who just as qualified to talk about nine 11 does compensation by
helicopters.
I'm saying until you have someone on like that fuel doesn't mail.
No.
Let me finish this point.
This is important because until you have someone on like that,
you're doing a monkey fist and Joe Rogan,
baby monkey,
I will do that and do that with my opponent hung food guy.
You're doing that intellectually because you're not having someone who would it
be able to argue those points,
but I'm not here to art in all fairness.
Guess what?
I can't argue those points either.
If you have someone like that,
I would have to bring on an actual religious scholar who's an atheist.
Yeah.
But I mean,
you know,
you obviously have your,
your,
you push it and you have every right to,
it's,
it's your promo.
You do as well.
If you go on and say that you're a Christian and I say,
well,
what do you believe?
Yeah.
I think just between two gentlemen.
That's a fair discussion.
Yeah.
But it's,
no,
there's,
there's no doubt that the way you approach it is certainly more aggressive than
someone who's an atheist than someone who is anything.
You give them more of a pass and someone who may be claims to be a Christian,
but that's not even the main focus on what I talk about.
You know what I'm saying?
Okay.
I got confused.
So you're saying I give atheist more of a path?
Yeah.
You give them more leeway.
Oh,
am I believe in anything,
but I do.
Sure they do.
What are they doing?
Millions and millions of people killed the name of atheism.
Stalin.
Mao.
Oh,
no,
no.
It's not.
What I mean though,
that's not what I mean.
I'm saying how about they do believe in ideology.
A lot of them.
There is an atheist ideology,
the new atheists,
hey,
but the atheist ideology doesn't involve mysticism and magic,
right?
Some pitocin slut.
Like what does,
when you have people who do well,
let's,
let's use it this way,
right?
Let's say I don't understand the Bible in its entirety.
I'm not a theologian.
Um,
do you really think that people who are going to be right now going into schools
with dormers understand the intricate science of the Big Bang?
Well,
I don't think anybody understands that.
They
understand where it go.
So there's no mystery.
Sure.
Something happened.
There's no mechanism to that.
Well,
there's definitely,
I mean,
Terence Mckenna had this brilliant thing about science,
you know,
and he was saying that science wants one miracle.
They want one miracle.
You give us one miracle and then we'll allow everything else.
We'll figure out,
we'll,
we'll explain to you multi-celled organisms will explain,
explain to you carbon molecules.
What we want is one mirror.
How did we want it to come from down in life?
No,
the big bang itself is the one miracle.
Something come from nothing.
Well,
not just something come from nothing.
How does something smaller than the head of the pin explode and become the
entire universe?
How does something that has so much mass and is so fucking infinitely small,
why does it explode?
Like why does it explode right now?
Even saying that the big bang existed,
I've never heard someone adequately,
adequately explained,
maybe I'm wrong,
but adequately explain why it happened.
Right.
I don't think they know well,
yes,
and my point is,
does anybody know?
Does anybody say they?
No,
not that I know of.
I don't think they say they know what Ben Carson are up to about.
Like when he's a neurosurgeon,
the big bang is one of the ones that I think you got to go.
Well I think they think that this happened because they have,
you know,
radio frequencies that they can discover and they can,
they can monitor and measure and we know Dawkins explanation.
I mean,
how do you sit there?
No mysticism.
That may be maybe these cells came on the back of crystals.
What is it that,
what's that?
That's what he said in the movie with Ben Stein.
Well,
maybe we think that maybe some of these molecules came in,
you know,
on the backs of foreign crystals,
foreign crystal Crystal's came in the big bang.
How do we get this life?
I mean it was questioned on it.
I'm thinking that sounds mystical to me.
I think at a certain point something has taken on faith.
My point is this,
what we're arguing about Islam,
Christianity,
all others,
we're talking pragmatically,
what's the effect?
What's the geopolitical effect?
What are the ramifications?
I think it's really easy to simplify and you want people in the comment section
going with Zombie Jesus who you know didn't exist.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
It's just as easy for someone to say so you have someone who's not you but you
and your,
you know,
a lounge chair with a box of cheezits who has no meaning whatsoever and truly
believes that a a bang happened and all of a sudden Joe Rogan's drinking is
fresh French press.
You can simplify anything and make it sound absurd and that's why I go back to,
I think they're smart people smarter than me on both sides and my mind is likely
to change.
Their mind is not likely to change in the second amendment.
My mind is not likely to change free speech.
It's not likely to change in the fact that uh oh Muhammad was a bastard.
Well,
I'm certainly with you on a lot of that,
but I think that what they're talking about when they're talking about mystical
occurrences during the time period of written history,
which is what they're talking about when you're talking about the,
the age of Jesus you're,
you're with,
these are like times where we do understand the parameters of actual possible
things that could have happened.
Sure.
You know,
like people coming back from the dead.
We have no evidence ever than anybody's ever been able to come back from the
dead means it doesn't.
It doesn't seem likely that that's true.
A whole different conversation.
But we also know that is there a possibility of a miracle which you require for
the big bang.
And I require for,
I don't necessarily on a train,
I require a miracle for the big bang.
I think there's missing science.
I think that there's look first and there's missing evidence from the,
you know,
a good example,
right?
This argument using right now,
okay,
I want to get it right because this is,
I'm not a theologian.
What is the hardest but argument?
But an argument was used for a long time.
It's kind of what you're,
there's no proof of that.
So for the longest time people said,
because David was as huge,
influential historical figure,
right?
And they're going,
well,
David,
up until 1993 they go,
and this is a guy,
this giant kingdom,
right?
This is the guy.
There should be some historical evidence and there's none until 1993 boom.
More evidence than you could possibly imagine on David.
His name on marble stone here is David,
is his kingdom as a historical figure.
Now,
nobody denies that he existed and nobody denies that the lineage of the kings
who were listed in the old testament existed when they claim to.
Now before that,
the big argument was there would be some kind of proof of of King David and
there isn't.
So the real issue is not evidence of absence.
The real issue with that argument is anytime you're dealing with things that are
2000 years old plus like good luck finding anything.
Yeah,
but we didn't know.
Yeah.
I mean we find some things but I'm saying like saying,
well I'm,
I'm arguing for you.
I'm saying like saying that something doesn't exist because we haven't found
evidence.
Like boy there's not a lot of evidence from 2000 years ago.
Right.
I mean that is a long fucking time and 2000 years of erosion and water and
natural disasters and all.
I mean everything gets lost.
We have a great bid on that.
And I actually had a bit similar that sucked and I asked it,
um,
cause you said it better if I send you into the forest,
how long before you send me an email?
If I send you into the woods with a hatchet,
how long you could send me any,
sorry,
I butchered it.
Simplifies it.
And I was like,
I had a bit about like going back to the witch trials and trying to explain to
them,
you know,
germ theory and a microscope and it just didn't work.
And I heard you do that.
And I'm like,
all right mom.
Just getting rid of that.
Well,
my bit was about dumb people.
Outbreeding smart people.
And by the way,
this came out before that.
What does that movie about retards?
Um,
can't say idiocracy idiocracy it came out the bit was on TV before idiocracy
okay,
so people use Gulu?
No.
Why The valley?
That is almost exactly like yours on vegans in milk.
Oh,
but I'm not,
I'm not asking it because I like it.
Let's keep going.
I'm on your salad.
I'll let you steal my shit.
It's already to Ncua.
There's evidence to be doing it back to oh eight.
That's go on.
I'm just doing it before that.
Were you doing the Vegan bit before eight milk camels?
Yeah,
it had to be formed.
It took a while.
Yeah.
Like 25 minutes.
Vegan bed,
put it on TV.
I think in 2013 14 it was in Colorado,
Rocky Mountain.
And that was,
uh,
but I,
I had ideas for that for a while.
The milk part was just one part of it.
The real part was about the remote shut the fuck up about being vegans.
But um,
the,
the thing about the,
um,
the idiocrasy thing,
the was about the pyramids.
It was about the dumb people outbreeding smart people and that like if one day,
like what would we do if one day no one fucked the smart people and we didn't
even realize that they died off.
And then one day the power just shuts off.
And what do you do when the power shut off?
I don't know what you do,
but I just sit around and wait because I figure,
well there's somebody.
Yeah,
but after a while,
like we'd be wandering through the streets,
like,
who's fucking turn the power?
But does anybody,
do you guys know nothing?
You hear anything?
Fuck you the best.
Mike goes down,
you're like,
well,
can't,
there's a wire here.
Yeah,
and it plugs in there and that's about the extent.
There's very few people because the compartmentalization of our society's very
few people,
if any,
that understand all of it.
That understanding the power grid that understand the purification of the water,
that understand the government,
that understand the computers,
technology,
the Internet.
There's very few people that could recreate all the things.
Yeah.
And most of us rely on a bunch of other people that are experts in order to keep
this insane machine we call technology going.
So my theory on the pyramids was that dumb people out,
fuck the smart people and left behind this whole thing and then the dumb people
would show up.
There was no one in the pyramid.
The Piccolo supposed to get out checks on Friday and there's nobody there and
then eventually no centricity down there that needs to be protested.
There was the thing,
the burning of the library of Alexandria,
I mean that really is kind of evidence of that.
That's what really would happen.
I mean then there is this,
the other thing that people like a lot of black people or African Americans want
to talk about,
um,
you know the pyramids and that the pyramids were built by black people,
but it's it,
they were built by Africans for sure because Egypt was Africa and it is in
Africa.
But the people from the south,
like there was,
there was black or Africans that came in and killed the Egyptians that were
there.
And that's why the Sphinx has an African face as an African looking face as
opposed to you've looked at African face nostrils clips.
Yeah.
Don't you love with Shaun King?
The pictures of him as a kid has strawberry blonde UCM.
I started on curves and every picture he takes,
he's flaring his nostrils.
He's reading in and like,
that is the most racist thing.
It's like,
hold on,
let me get a black too.
I picture of black.
I do that.
You kind of like gorilla,
like a really likes,
you know,
sniffle.
They tried to say black people who grew up in you,
son of a bitch.
I can't believe you.
Well,
that's what just happened with that Quentin Tarantino and you see that he,
he savage think pieces people wrote about me and they go,
you said sad,
the gs calling black people saboteurs and I was like,
that's the thing with these,
you know Tina was more leftist.
Same thing with Matt Damon.
I just love seeing these people are progressive and they like to separate from
themselves and the social justice warrior cult.
It's the monster.
They've created it.
They deserve to be.
Well,
Amy Schumer got attacked.
She got attacked for some of the bits that she did on her show.
She's up on stage pushing gun control with a,
with her third cousin twice removed.
I think she deserves,
well you do realize that she had a movie that came out and there was a mass
shooting in the movie theater where her movie was being played.
I mean that's got to fuck with your head.
Yeah,
yeah,
I'm sure.
Oh they were playing trainwreck while some guy opened fire.
Therefore I'm directly responsible and I'm going to remove your right to self
preservation.
I don't follow the logic trail.
Is she trying to remove your right?
I mean,
what is she trying to say?
I don't know what she's actually pushing legislation with chuck there in a,
in New York,
Chuck Schumer senator.
It's part of our,
oh,
that is one of her cousins like third removed just when she's up on stage
pushing that.
You know,
I talked about that when you have Sarah Silverman saying it's time for Comedians
to get with the times and when you have Harrison green mom coming on saying,
I'll support free speech but I won't support hate speech.
It's a very,
you know,
you have a lot of comedians who came out and said that,
um,
what Nicole Arbor said,
which is wildly offensive and fat shaming cola was the girl with the shaming
thing.
They see that youtube video I just thought wasn't well done.
And I thought when she went on the view,
first of all,
you're walking right into the lion's den,
a bunch of Chubby broads on that show,
you know?
Well,
they've got to Raymond Raven Simone now.
it was really hilarious is one of their arguments was,
you know,
a lot of people just get addicted to certain foods.
Like is I think that's what she's saying.
Well one of the things,
Michelle Collins comedian and their joy bay Har Comedian and uh,
and,
and they're giving her the rules on comedy.
Well she didn't do a good job defending herself cause she tried to do shtick.
No,
no,
no.
I'm not going to do Michelle Collins.
Enjoy Bay harsh should absolutely feel a shame for telling her like Joy Bay is
going,
you know,
but listen,
you're skinny blonde,
you know,
whatever.
I make my jumps because I'm fat.
I first joke about myself,
you have to be so really joined bay,
how you're a Christian conservative cause that's what you make fun of all the
time.
It's just stupid stupid idea.
Now they're prescribing rules of comedy wants,
they're offended and I won't go down that trail at all.
And I don't think Nicole Arbor,
it's funny,
but that's what they're gonna do.
They're gonna attack you and say,
I don't think you're funny.
Therefore you shouldn't say this.
I'm not going to say I couldn't agree more in that way.
Yeah.
And I think that what she did was kind of Clunky,
but you know,
she's not,
I don't think she's a real standout issues.
Is She?
Yeah.
From Canada.
She's not,
she's not fantastic,
but she says,
I don't think she's a real stand up.
Now listen.
You know what though?
I think about it though.
I really believe that the,
you're kind of in America,
Canada or North America do want to get it sort of.
So I guess all those Canadians there and the shows from which you took part,
they were idiots.
They weren't funny.
Listen,
very funny guys.
Not standups.
Yeah,
but they're still coming about that.
Hmm.
Well,
you know,
the comedian,
actually a French Canadian means actor too.
I asked if they were stand up.
Stand up.
Well,
she still is actually doing stand up now.
He d well,
let me see,
was for a while.
Last time I spoke to him,
he's uh,
started doing standup to pay the bills.
He's got a horrible,
horrible,
horrible divorce story.
Dave Foley,
if you go and Google the day Foley divorce store,
I believe it's online and a youtube clip that,
um,
Brandon made,
it's fucking insane.
But my point is,
let's go back.
This is important.
Okay.
Michelle Collins.
[inaudible],
Sarah Silverman,
Amy Schumer,
that should just have your bs meter flinging out.
It should be gone firing so hot,
your,
your cap out goes fat shaming fat.
But when Sarah Silverman says it's,
it's not hard to get with the times when Amy Schumer pushes for gun control.
And is Sarah Silverman saying that about about gun control?
She was saying that I'm comedy when she was asked about and what is,
what is allowable and what's not.
She's like,
well,
you know,
I defend free speech.
But yeah,
it's not hard to get with the times.
Like I used to say gay and I don't think you should say that.
And she's basically saying that's gay now,
but it's not about that gay.
It's about either.
It's all okay.
Jim Norton makes a great art.
People don't acknowledge how intelligent he is.
Oh,
he's very intelligent.
I love Jimmy.
They're all okay or none of it.
So yeah.
Well,
I got a whole bit about this in my last special.
You probably saw it like the whole thing about the,
about not being able to joke about things.
Right.
You know what I'm saying?
When I say things on stage,
when I'm joking,
I do not mean them there.
Like I say,
a bunch of crazy shit.
And the reason I say that crazy shit is because it's funny.
Right?
And if it's not funny,
I wouldn't say it,
but there's some things that I say that are absolutely not true.
And I say them just because they're funny,
but there's some things that are true.
Yeah.
Like here's one.
My wife is tired of fucking me.
I go,
but she's still,
she,
it's true.
But she,
she doesn't,
she doesn't say no because if she had a raper,
so that's not true.
I joke around,
I go,
I wouldn't rape her.
The worst I do is hold her down the fucker butt cheeks.
That's not true either.
I wouldn't do that either.
And it's like this whole series of things,
it gets more and more preposterous.
I go,
I'm joking to get it.
You see how it's going on here?
I'm not raping anybody.
She's like one of my favorite people I wouldn't written then I'd say the rest of
it,
but it's like the,
the idea is,
do you know,
scan down.
It is not stand up is not truth.
It is sometimes truth.
Right.
But it is what is funny [inaudible] you know,
I'm fucking around right now.
You can't anymore.
And,
and here's the thing,
the progressive left,
sorry.
Like Silvermans the Schumers,
the Harrison green bombs,
the joy [inaudible] am I saying sorry and then doing that.
Sorry.
These names because I know they're standing,
you're probably your friends.
But when they,
Amy is my friend and Sarah is my friend.
I really enjoyed there.
I mean that was a kid when they were doing standup,
you know,
I think Sarah is one of the best comics on the planet.
I really do.
But she was a shock comic.
Of course.
That was a big part of her ass still.
She's saying it's not hard to get with the time.
So really what she's saying is,
you can joke about this but don't joke about this and it's sort of like the
wealthy 1% protecting their wealth.
A lot of these established comedians now said,
well,
what applies to you didn't apply to me.
And that's something,
a lot of these kids now you're going to see it migrate the people who are the
real free speech warriors,
like the SAR guns have a cat like the Karen Strawns.
Maybe they're not all comedians,
but they're going to be online because stand up is not the environment that you
came up in.
You may be able to say what you want to say,
but let me,
let me paint a picture for you.
Okay?
Cause you're super wealthy and successful and I'm not worthy.
Um,
but I'm talking about the kid who's coming up and I don't know,
Omaha,
Nebraska or maybe even here at the laugh factory open mic night,
who you just do the laugh factory open Mike night,
make you stay in line.
I can't imagine day.
And then you come back a week later.
It's bullshit.
The point is that could gets up and makes a tranny Joe.
Right,
right.
Someone complains and threatened with a lawsuit.
Maybe the booker isn't a social justice warrior,
but you think he's going to say something.
You know what?
Let's just book another comment.
I'm not going to take that risk.
That's what happens and for me to see comedians supporting it,
I think you're seeing this sort of a passing of the guard with stand up to a lot
of these truth tellers online because they're not beholden to those rules.
Right.
I see what you're saying.
I don't know what Sarah meant when she said that and I don't know what context
she said it in,
but when you say that she's a shot comic,
most of our shocking stuff was kind of self deprecating.
Like most of her shock.
I mean she wasn't attacking people.
Well,
Jesus has magic was a,
if you look at it,
there was a lot of stuff that was designed to prod Christians,
which is fine.
It's funny,
but Christians don't try and kill you rise.
I see what you're saying.
Well,
I haven't seen her do that with this long called Shiny happy Jihad.
I saw that.
Yeah it was,
it was good.
Was it was a little risky.
It was a little risky.
But again,
you do like what you did,
what you did [inaudible] that was way more risky.
Thank you Joe.
Yeah,
mine was just jokes about like suicide bombers,
Joe mine jokes were like,
you know,
like that I don't understand suicide bombing cause I was raised Catholic like in
no Catholics believe in it that much.
Right?
Like there's never going to be a Catholic suicide bomber cause we just don't
believe in it that much.
I'm an incredibly critical of Catholicism.
You know,
being raised in Quebec,
people don't understand that in the United States at first of all the rights
you're talking about.
Ironically when you're saying you don't want origined religion,
those rights come from people who said they came from God.
It doesn't come from man,
it doesn't come from wall.
So that is a part of our,
our laws here.
Well it also came from people that didn't have the Internet.
They were writing things down where they come from.
That was very unique.
This was the first society that said,
okay,
these rights don't come from us.
They come from God.
That was why freedom of speech exists right here.
But it's also the first society established itself.
The difference between Church and state.
Yes,
no,
exactly.
And if you read the,
you know,
like for example,
the separation of church and state,
it doesn't exist.
It's not in the constitution.
It's written from a taken from a private letter from Thomas Jefferson to the
Danbury baptists where he was talking about no establishment of a state
denomination because they were afraid of a certain denomination taking over fast
forward Quebec where I was raised,
I went to public school,
I went to Catholic school.
Catholicism is the provincial denomination in Quebec.
The United States didn't want that.
And a big portion of it is if you look in Europe and you look in in Canada where
Catholicism was so overbearing and you have these beautiful cathedrals in
Montreal that are entirely empty,
people reject the oppressive thumb of religion.
And that's why more Christians exist in the United States,
not because they're stupid and they're bumpkins,
but because they didn't have the oppressive religion,
so they didn't reject it as readily.
So,
um,
that makes sense.
Yeah.
So your,
um,
public school was a religious school?
Yeah,
it was and I was not a Catholic.
I got sent home quite a few times for argument.
The teachers,
what did you argue about?
Um,
well I,
I bitched when I wasn't allowed to take communion because I had taken commune
with my parents for a long time and my dad was like,
do you understand what this says?
Yeah,
I understand that.
Okay,
explain it to me.
fine.
You can take the bread from the basket.
But in Catholic church you can't do it.
It's a whole ceremony.
And a couldn't you?
Because I wasn't Catholic because he didn't officially taking it.
The Catholic Catholicism,
you didn't go through catechism all that.
And then I also had one,
and this will sound really silly to the atheist audience who aren't Christian,
so I'll get off it.
But they were teaching,
was taught about what's a saint kids.
And my school was Saint Francis of Assisi and my parents were always really
clear.
Like I had a dad who gave me the sex talk when I was three.
He gave me sort of three,
three,
damn,
I got sick,
I got a call at home and a preschool.
This is a,
my dad sounds like a home alone.
It's like,
no,
that's like dom.
I rare his joke.
Yeah.
Well he didn't want me to learn about it in school and think it was dirty.
Oh,
okay.
I got it really young and I actually,
even preschool Catholic school,
they were talking about what's a,
her name was Miss Mary and her daughter was in my class,
Monica.
And so she was giving us the whole like stork business and this is in preschool,
like I'm four or five.
And I go,
no,
that's not,
let me break it down for you.
That's how it works.
But the pro and then her,
um,
her daughter was in class.
So whatever lie,
she tells it home,
she has to keep alive for the class because their daughters,
their daughters,
like there's nothing,
there's no egg.
It's a tin can and a tummy and ended baby growth in a tin can.
And at this point I'm going like when my dad told me a penis,
vagina,
egg,
cell fertilization,
you know,
but how old were you?
I would have been four.
So four.
She's talking about tin cans,
but talking about 10 cans and I go up to the teacher,
I'm like,
well you're,
you know Monica is saying it's a tin can tell her nigga she was Steven.
It's a 10 camp,
like a p cat.
Oh,
what a bitch.
And I go home line or your kid lying to me.
I go home.
I remember asking my Dad,
I go,
dad is there like a king and a woman's stomach?
And this is just what my dad is.
He never baby tacos.
He just goes,
no,
that's the stupidest thing I've ever heard in my life.
I wouldn't lie to you.
And that was it.
Wow.
So I knew that stuff.
I want to,
you got in trouble for that?
Well yeah cause she had to keep the live for her daughter.
Like what kind of trouble they can call home.
Like he's Steven's being inappropriate.
Wow.
If that was my fucking kid,
if I went to school in this dumb cunt is trying to tell my kid is a tin can
grown inside some woman's uterus.
Jesus Christ.
Well,
my dad did.
My Dad went in and uh,
we had a teacher,
I'll say her name cause I can't send her Mrs Lake.
She kicked me out of class.
Mrs Lake.
You know why she kicked me out of class?
Why?
Because I said there were 50 states.
She argued there were 52 what were the other two?
Alaska and Hawaii.
But that's 48 and the lower 48
well didn't Obama fuck that up?
I'm gonna fuck that up.
57 [inaudible] 57 yeah.
I thought he said 52 as well.
I said 57
when he was running for president.
You might have a fucking tired.
That guy must've been when he was running.
Right?
Wasn't it?
Especially with that much.
He drinks.
Does he drink a lot?
But it was his annual physical that came back like,
ah,
you're mostly good.
Just stop drinking so much.
Really?
How do you know this?
What was released.
Yeah.
People telling me recently and George Bushes physical.
No,
you may not like them,
but you never saw him.
He was running marathons.
Uh,
his last year of his presidency bench to two oh five for five reps.
That's pretty good for an old dude.
That's not bad.
He's got that like chimpanzee.
Why Erie strength?
But that old Charles Bronson deal.
Yeah.
Well he does a lot of really shitty paintings too.
You ever see us push?
Never seen his artwork.
I haven't.
No.
Oh,
it's really horrendously bad.
Perfect.
Yeah,
that's right.
One to bring up Lena Dunham's Dad's painting.
Yeah.
Well I want to also bring up why I keep,
we keep bringing her up.
You had a really good video because she's just started bringing her up.
How dare you.
Yeah.
I don't know you Lena.
I'm sure you're a very nice person.
She's not.
The video was very interesting because you were,
you were talking about this,
this whole story where she had come up with this book and in the book she was
talking about a time that she was raped,
but you highlighted her actual words that like when she was with this guy,
she started talking dirty to him.
This is before they even had sex,
she started talking dirty and to asking him if she,
if he wanted to do this and he wanted to do that and then he did those things
and then her friends are saying,
oh my God,
you got raped.
Like what kind of a fucking world are we living in that?
People are talking about that and not highlighting the ambiguity of talking
dirty to somebody,
not highlighting the mixed signals and you went over that.
I thought very respectfully.
I thought you did it really and I failed.
It wasn't meant to be respectful at all.
You were on,
you were honest about it and you weren't insulting.
You didn't,
it wasn't sold.
I dressed up like Lena Dunham.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's it.
That's trans face now,
but if you dress up like me is that if you're a girl and you were a this fucking
shirt,
is that it?
Am I ain't going to be insulted.
I Dunno.
That's not insulting to me.
If you dress like me,
I've never invite get us all come in like you dead.
You would be a guy dressing like a guy.
But I'm saying if you were a girl and you dress like me,
would I be like that insulting bitch?
Like why would that be insulting?
I don't understand that,
but because I mocked her.
Well,
you mocked what she said and you also mocked it because it was being paraded
around as if it made sense and it's fucking confusing.
Well,
that's the whole promise.
Yeah.
Are you wearing a wig?
Beautiful beeper wig.
I was like,
I wouldn't really,
well now she's changed your hair so many times.
She has a little little Lord Fauntleroy rave or whatever it is.
Haircut.
I see.
Yeah.
I guess this is,
this is old.
Yeah.
It was pretty mocking.
No,
that's an old,
that's an old one.
That's one.
This is a parody one.
The other one,
you weren't dressed like that and I was worried you were dressed like my
standard Lena Dunham outfit.
My point is the media doesn't call her on it.
And so,
and this is where I talk about kind of,
we all have blind spots.
He did,
not only did they not talk,
they didn't call her on it.
They didn't make her explain how like this is a like expo.
If you could tell the story because a lot of people probably don't know what
we're even talking about.
Tell the story that is in her book.
Um,
so late it Dunham claimed she was raped in her book.
She claimed she was raped by a mustachioed Republican.
She code named and Barry,
she said it was a night where muscle relaxers,
Xanax and alcohol took them back to her place.
She was peeing in a parking lot and he stuck his fingers in her nether regions.
And uh,
then she got home and she wasn't sure how she felt about it and she went ahead
with it and talk dirty to them.
Then I think while they're finishing up,
she saw a condom in the house plant and realize he had taken off a condom.
And then the next morning her friends told her she had been raped.
So everyone runs with us and they hold around is this rape survivor.
And here's the thing,
it's not that hard to track down the guy she's talking about.
I'm not a journalist.
It took about three or four phone calls.
Um,
and I won't get an,
I really don't want to go to that cause the guy obviously,
you know,
it can destroy his life where he's accused of raping someone has wife and kids.
Um,
here's the thing too,
when you talk about in the Republican either,
right?
Um,
I again,
I don't wanna get into personal stuff.
Okay.
No need to,
cause I don't wanna destroy his life.
You know,
people say rape destroys your life.
It does.
But falsely accusing a guy of rape is incredibly destructive as well.
And they don't have any recourse.
The legal system is entirely designed to prosecute.
End of story.
And you know,
same thing.
If you want to get custody of your kids.
So no one called her on it.
And um,
that's what I did the video on that if this is a huge disservice to rape victims
to women who are actually raped,
you know,
Lena Dunham goes out and says one in four women are raped.
I will tell you this.
I don't believe that statistic and the general population,
it's far less,
but at like feminist film festivals,
I think four out of three women are raped.
Everyone,
their claims to have been raped.
And these you'd think,
you know,
the more attractive you are,
the chances of being raped would go up.
Right.
I'm not robbing family dollar,
I'm going to go for the jeweler.
But apparently there's this,
an epidemic of purple pitted,
fatty,
Androgynous,
ambiguous feminists just getting raped by roaming packs.
That's what they want us to believe.
Well,
what,
it depends on what,
how you define rape because regret this rape all pee,
all regretful.
P In v what they teach in College [inaudible] v Penis and Vagina.
Regretful,
penis and Vagina is rape.
Yeah.
That.
That one is a really weird one to me.
Um,
I talked to Thaddeus Russell on the podcast about Occidental College where they
had that case where these two kids got drunk and they had sex and the girl was
saying to her,
friends,
I'm about to get laid,
lol.
You know,
he coming over,
do you have condoms?
Texting this guy,
guy comes over,
they have sex.
Afterwards she decides,
someone decides that it,
it was raped because she was intoxicated.
Completely ignoring the fact that he was intoxicated as well.
Yeah.
They were both drunk kids that had sex.
And you know what,
man,
when I was young,
that's what it was.
It was drunk.
People had sex and nobody felt like they got raped because they were drunk.
My wife rips me on the regular.
People make mistakes,
you know?
I mean,
people I've had sex with,
people I go after it was over was like,
oh,
I probably shouldn't drink so much.
We've all,
we've all been there,
we've all been there before.
Everybody who drinks and is young and especially when you're young,
you don't really know how to drink well you don't.
Yeah.
You don't have a large database of things to pull back from.
Like,
okay,
I've been down this road before.
The third shot of Jack is where shit goes downhill.
Whole purple haired,
five by five feminists starts looking pretty good.
People make mistakes,
man.
And you can't say that it's a fucking crime because you both engaged in a
consensual activity,
but you don't like it after it was over.
So it doesn't,
it doesn't matter.
But my point was that kid,
the boy got kicked out of the college.
The girl stayed.
They were both,
exactly.
They both participated.
They both were agreeable.
They both,
they mean,
she asked him,
come over,
do you have condoms?
He said,
I'm on my way.
Right.
They got together,
they had sex and because there was alcohol involved,
the girl was raped,
which is insane.
Well,
mattress girl,
you fell like almost invariably these cases come up and they're just lies there.
Just follow the rolling stone story.
Yeah,
the rolling stone story.
Um,
but Lena Dunham is so bad cause then she's holding it.
She's holding herself out of this rape survivor and you know she's molested her
little sister and she's just a bad human being.
And you'll,
you can bring up her dad's paintings.
Carroll Dunham.
I mean there's some weird stuff,
Carol.
Yeah.
Carol,
can we bring that up?
Her Dad's named Carol.
Can we do this?
Does it or dudes named Carol Carol show Shelby Carroll.
Shelby.
That's all he drew.
Wait a minute.
What the fuck is that?
That's her dad's painting.
Oh my God.
Her Dad's got a painting of a woman.
Her ass a,
that's all he drew.
That was his thing.
Just a woman from behind asses and vaginas.
Angry vaginas and this weird cart.
Yeah,
they're like baboons asses.
Yeah.
Now you don't think some weird stuff went on in that household.
Oh,
and this is the girl.
I mean she,
what did she do to her sister?
There was something that she admitted that she didn't like.
She reached in with her fingers,
she said because her sister put pebbles in her vagina and she also said she
would like,
she acted like a Predator where she would try and lure her sister,
like pay her to kiss her and she masturbated in bed next to her little sister.
What the fuck are these drawings?
You weren't down.
This is a healthy balanced individual.
Come on like let's just add up.
You can't guarantee it,
but add up the pieces to the puzzle.
And she's the feminist.
Uh,
she,
she's the new Barbara Streisand,
right?
She's out there.
And my issue was the media didn't call on it front page Huffpo,
CNN,
MSNBC,
you,
Lena Dunham bravely comes out about being a rape survivor.
And when I see leftist go in the corporate media man and they're buying Lena
Dunham wholesale,
that's what bothers me.
But look at that one,
this petition,
discuss talking strange.
You just get,
you know,
have you ever seen Jack Kevorkian?
His drawings?
I saw it,
yeah.
Some of them,
Like what the fuck?
This is kind of along those lines along those lines where it's like,
oh,
okay.
I mean,
I'm a big fan of artistic freedom.
You should be able to do whatever the fuck you want.
But can we not show this on Youtube?
Is that where you're not putting it up online?
Oh,
okay.
People are going to have to,
yeah,
I'm just looking at say they're over 18 well,
it seems to me like God damn it man.
This is really weird shit.
So she gives her something that's objectification to mean.
This isn't just a beautiful woman face the angry vagina.
That's what I'm saying.
Well,
they're all buttholes and angry vaginas and when you do get ahead on view,
Jamie,
click on the one above the head on view.
You don't see the face.
Look at that girl that like in the middle there on that.
Yeah,
right there.
Let me from the rain.
Exactly what the fuck is going on with her nipples.
She,
first of all,
she looks like she's dead and drowning.
Right?
Or She's drowned and now she's Pale and white.
That looks like a drowning victim.
Like her legs are underwater.
The claim.
It's pointing out the irony or the pay.
I don't know.
It's just so striking in patriarchy.
So that's what my point is.
She's emblematic of everything that's wrong with social justice,
Warrior culture and our show just sucks.
[inaudible] which shows that girls on Hbo,
I've never seen it.
Well,
you know it's the perfect example,
right?
You hear about it everywhere.
Everyone,
all these Emmy's,
they're lucky to get 600,000 viewers on girls.
The ratings are terrible,
but HBO wants to push it because they believe the messaging is important.
What's the messaging?
That's all the feminists leftest tolerance bs that Lena Dunham pushes.
They've decided Lena Dunham is important enough that they're going to prop her
up despite the fact that an episode of curb your enthusiasm or game of Thrones
can get 10 times the viewership.
But it's important for the rape survivor to have a show and it's not true.
Is that really why you think they do it?
You don't think that that's a for profit enterprise?
Why would they do it otherwise?
Well,
don't you think?
They think they do it because it like balances out there programming or makes
them seem more area dite balances it out from what?
Hbo Is always to the Left.
No one like thinks like game of Thrones isn't to the left.
Oh,
game of Thrones is inconsequential.
It's you know the kind of kids who will argue with fucking awesome.
First of all,
watch your tongue.
I am not a big fan.
How dare you.
I'm not a big fan of my friend Natasha is Yaro.
She calls it make 'em ups.
She doesn't like any fiction.
She's like,
I don't like make 'em ups because they just make shit up like,
oh all of a sudden she gave birth to dragons.
You can't just make stuff up like that,
but you can't.
And game of Thrones.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I just didn't,
I just couldn't get into it.
The walking dead is my show.
Okay,
here's my take on the walking dead.
The new one is fucking better.
I like the dead.
It's better with the daddy or shows played a terrorist until this a real well,
he's only ever been poor guy.
But you know what?
He broke out of it,
man.
He did good for him.
You know what broke through the brown seal.
This is an episode.
I don't want to bring it up,
but when he went,
Joe,
I don't want to bring it up.
What am I lying?
He went jogging and he comes home.
He's all sweaty and then the next scene he doesn't have any sweat and then the
next scene he's sweating and looking back.
Yeah,
they go back and forth to him being soaked with sweat and no sweat and soak
sweat.
Very,
very shitty job.
Whoever was the,
the set person that dealt with the wardrobe continuity with the sweat spray.
Well,
that's a real problem with girls because Lena Dunham has a severe perspiration
problem.
She doesn't shower as well.
What do you mean she doesn't shower?
I'm making stuff up.
I want to spell it.
How dare you see now you're proud of the problem.
Then you need to get laid at denim,
but you are what you are is what they think you are.
Then you'd be dipping.
And I am me this,
she mean when someone like Lena Dunham,
you claim rape falsely.
I know I've,
I know someone very close to me who was raped.
Um,
the same thing,
you know,
my wife and I,
we volunteer,
but you're her more so at a special needs place.
And so when people fame this offense at re retarded,
I've watched special needs people call other special needs people retarded.
Well,
the problem is retarded doesn't mean down syndrome.
It just doesn't.
And you know the real well,
they used to put on people's birth certificates when they were born with down
syndrome.
They used to call them mongoloid idiots.
That was literally what they used to put the medical term for someone who had
down syndrome.
Like what?
Retarded is to retard growth.
What does that mean?
That you are slow.
You are behind.
Like if you're a fucking dummy,
you're retarded.
What do you do?
The word retarded,
Tama talk like,
oh,
excuse me,
wash y'all.
Hotdog means,
sorry,
I'm late.
Ah,
taller needs to be late to be slow to arrive and it comes from us.
All the romance languages come from Latin.
And so that's where it comes from.
Which just like Negro is not racist.
And Doe people sat it was racist and they forgot to tell all the United Negro
College Fund this or how about the only other way paint,
that's the craziest one.
National Association for the advancement of colored people.
Like what is funny about her that was funny about that woman,
you know,
the uh,
the Rachel Dolezal check who was actually really white and pretended to be black
and had the fake Tan and all that jazz.
It's hilarious.
But what's hilarious is she is of color.
She's white.
You know,
it was not only that the NAACP was founded by white people,
was made by white progressive and when it was founded,
black people couldn't even hold.
They couldn't be in a position of leadership.
They weren't allowed to,
which is kind of fucked up.
Well,
what's funny,
what I find so funny about her as now the whole Trans phobic thing is a new
movement.
I think she has a black baby inside of her that she was pregnant.
It's like a,
uh,
she's blames Cameron Scifi Film.
Listen,
she's pregnant and you know that she's fucking black guys,
right?
She's saying,
don't know for a fact.
I wouldn't doubt it.
I'm going to bet a lot how much
I'm pushing the fuck and pilot ships and that she fucked a black guy.
Not to say anything wrong with that.
Here's what's so wrong with that whatsoever.
I just want to say that right away,
but I think maybe she wanted to have,
be a little more black.
She had a brother Shaun king too.
I mean,
listen,
we don't aspire to,
they don't aspire to be,
you know,
architects and aspire to be scientists.
They aspire to be professional victims that we ha,
that's what you have with Sean King.
I'm we with Rachel Dolezal all this money in that it's not just money.
There's,
there's,
I mean,
I shouldn't say this money in it,
but what I should say,
there's,
there's success in that.
Like,
if you can tap into that vein quite easily,
it doesn't require a lot of thinking and you,
you immediately get people that won't challenge it because it's one of those
things like if you,
if you become one of those people that becomes a professional victim,
boy,
you don't get challenged much.
It's just,
it's hands.
And I can see the headlines Right now at salon two white guys talk about the,
a black American left.
Well,
in all fairness,
I am Sicilian mostly,
and that means that I am of mixed heritage them.
He's my,
there's a black man would pile somewhere they were raped by the Moore's.
You saw true,
true romance.
That's the fact Mike fucking grandparents were from Sicily.
Black man jumping out of the shed somewhere down with one of your female is more
of a dark Muslim character.
Right.
The Moore's,
I think there were,
uh,
they were from Africa though.
One thing I thought about Rachel Dolezal you've got right.
Thinking about her a lot.
I do.
Uh,
the sideshow,
Bob is just,
it does it for me.
I think a,
you know a Cho Bob?
He had a sideshow Bob Hairdo.
Oh,
I don't even know what you mean that.
It's funny.
What does in sideshow,
shoebox trusty sidekick.
That's where it's from.
That's,
can you picture it now?
Yeah,
I can bring up slide show about.
Think about this for a second.
Well,
she had to do that.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's hilarious.
But she had to do that in order to look funny.
She did the black white girl hair,
so she got the perm,
but then she liked the light brown parent.
You're not the only one.
Look who did it better.
But here's the crazy thing.
Okay.
People say,
well,
Trans Racial thing,
transgender rights isn't in the thing.
Well,
that's what I'm saying.
Look,
Caitlin Jenner or Fallon Fox,
right.
Caitlyn Jenner can go through hormone replacement therapy,
get all the plastic surgery,
start changing his voice and guess what?
People see them and they still realize that's a dude.
Well,
you know,
it's Rachel knows all slapped on a tan and a perm and fooled the NAACP.
You tell me what's more realist.
Well,
she did go to an all black college and she got a scholarship day,
right?
Yeah,
but you go to Morehouse.
I don't know her.
I know Shaun King.
I know Shaun King got the black thing from Oprah.
What do you mean?
Yeah,
he got some kind of a scholarship for being a victim of a hate crime and he's a
black guy.
But what's funny is the actual police report from that crime,
he checked the Caucasian box.
So it's not only on your person,
that's a WHO's on first routine in the
no hate crime.
He has a black man.
You checked Caucasian.
That's right.
Oh my God.
Fuck.
I forgot what I was going to say because we were talking about,
that's so funny.
You broke my brain.
Oh,
the transgender thing.
That's what it was.
My fucking five year old man was watching Caitlyn Jenner on the,
the the show,
whatever it was when I am Cait,
whatever.
And she goes,
Mommy,
why is that man to ask why I got girl,
the five year old said that and my wife just covered her mouth like this.
Yeah.
That was me with my dad,
cause my,
and my daughter was serious.
She was serious.
She was like,
Mommy,
why is that man dress bag girl say it's normal.
It's weird.
She's beautiful.
You go girl.
My friend Whitney Cummings or I talked about this too many times,
I can't talk about it anymore.
She put it on her Instagram hero with a picture of him.
Mike,
I don't see a fireman.
I'm not.
See,
I don't see a first responder.
And he and he killed a guy.
Yes.
A girl.
Woman.
Oh girl.
That's right.
And pushed her into a real woman,
pushed her into traffic by spacing out behind the wheel and slamming a buck
angel who challenged me to a fight because I wrote about Fallon Fox and I was
like,
I mean,
did she write,
I wrote that.
Okay.
This was my argument.
This was a long time ago.
I read it when I was at Fox News and before anyone else was talking to him about
it,
I said okay,
because it wasn't really a national story.
Right.
Uh,
Christianne Cyborg,
right.
She had her belt removed Strikeforce because they found out she popped for
steroids.
Remember,
cause she took me on hormones.
Hormones,
right?
So they said,
okay,
that's enough.
We're going to take away your belt.
Right?
Why?
Because it's an unfair advantage.
Um,
well,
it's not just an unfair advantage.
It's a banned substance.
It's not even natural to your body.
Right?
Well,
my whole point is Fallon Fox has been taking steroids,
uh,
parole life.
They're called balls,
right?
Because if you actually look at a woman taking steroids,
it's still nowhere near the hormonal advantage that a man has over a woman.
As a matter of fact,
Arnold Schwartzenegger like a walking human pin cushion in his prime doesn't
enjoy the hormonal advantage over me that I enjoy over the basic woman.
It's that much of a gap.
So to act like it goes away because you know,
you,
you grab a hair straightener and you put on a bikini,
it's just not accurate.
And she,
and buck angel was like owl town.
I'm like,
first off,
there's a reason for weight classes.
Secondly,
of course we need to have the HIV testing all that cause you're a porn star.
Thirdly,
I'm not going to fight you.
You wouldn't fight.
Buck Buck's a nice guy,
but he's not that big and you're a lot bigger person.
When Buck Buck has a folio frame,
she,
he has small hands and small shoulders and this is the thing that it's hiding
behind the bully pulpit.
A gotten a woman like that.
No where else I'd be like,
Hey Stephen,
I want to fight you.
But because you said this about Fallon,
Fox was entirely accurate by the way,
and I stand by it.
I walk it back zero.
The whole trans community has to tell me I'm hateful.
Meanwhile Fallon Fox just beating the crap out of women and you know,
there's no technique there.
Alan Fox is not a good fighter.
It's just pure strength.
It looks very much like domestic violence.
Well it does when you watch it,
it really does.
And she's not very,
very technical and there's also really a problem.
There's a,
my friend Steph Daniel's wrote a piece for bloody elbow.
She wrote several pieces about this issue and she did a very good job of being
completely objective and interviewing a bunch of different experts on it and she
found that there is a big discrepancy between gender reassignment doctors,
quote unquote experts who have one opinion on it,
right?
You are a woman now,
you have no advantages whatsoever and those are the people that they,
they've talked to the,
you know,
the IOC and they've,
made it so that in the Olympics is no discrepancy.
But I,
my my,
my position is as a combat sports expert.
I think there's a giant difference between having a male frame and a female
frame.
Then there's this woman,
a doctor,
Ramona [inaudible],
who is a,
they wrote a piece for a bloody elbow and she went into great detail.
She's an endocrinologist,
board certified endocrinologist.
When do great detail about the significant advantages in bone density and the
fact that the bone density,
not only does it not decrease with the use of estrogen,
but estrogen is in fact what keeps bone density in women.
That's one of the reasons why when women dropped their estrogen,
as they get older,
they start getting osteoporosis.
And so she was saying that you have an advantage.
It preserves it.
Not only that,
there's advantages in terms of reaction time,
the,
the average man or everything physically standing on percent,
10% faster reaction time than a woman,
which is massively significant when you're talking about striking,
when you see guys like Roy Jones Jr did you lose tick still faster than you or
me by a long shot?
But he leaves overall.
I don't know about brunch to 75,
bro.
Dude,
I hear you bro.
You don't have the rage that I get.
I don't my,
uh,
mental,
but why don't you go into Joey Dee said
that was don my rare again.
I didn't even,
you'd have to kill me.
Um,
but the um,
uh,
reaction times quicker and also the fact that you live your whole life as a man,
like your,
your body is your tendons.
Trank there's so many different things.
So Dr Ramona critique puts his piece out.
They fucking attack.
Stephie they attacked her.
Great job.
Ruining all your great work because she had interviewed all these different
people with different opinions.
It wasn't even her opinion.
You know,
she,
she went to a board certified endocrinologist who had an objective point of
view,
right?
And this person said,
yes,
there's significant advantages here.
They are scientifically laid out.
Here's something I wrote about that.
No one else really talks about all these organic sort of leftist Hippie Gras,
right?
They want organic and they don't want BPH.
Well,
what's the big problem with BPA,
right?
Xeno estrogens,
the people talk about it mimics estrogen in the body and that leads to cancer,
right?
Too many estrogen,
too much estrogen in the body.
They talk about that drinking hormones in the milk.
They talk about that with BPA and pesticides.
So we all widely acknowledged that estrogen elevated beyond normal levels in the
human body.
It's probably not great,
right?
For Human Health when injected directly into your ball sack.
However,
we're supposed to turn a blind eye and say,
well,
the science isn't in yet for the transgender community,
but don't,
don't drink from that plastic bottle.
Make sure it's a mason jar.
They got lives for that,
you know,
but we have to,
but when they're doing direct estrogen injections,
well we don't know really well then don't buy organic and drink up your BPA.
It becomes uh,
an ideological issue.
More than becomes a scientific course and you,
you are not allowed.
It's like we were talking about when we were talking about abortion earlier.
You're not allowed to have a varying opinion,
right?
Like you have to stay within the line.
It's like you said that I'm considered a,
you know,
I would be considered a left wing by a lot of people,
but I'm on,
I'm in the NRA.
I'm not a kid.
I didn't want to bring it up.
Talk about it.
I think you should be allowed to have guns.
I don't think that guns are bad.
I think we have,
I've,
I've wrote about this,
that we have a mental health problem disguise as a gun problem.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's a real problem there.
There's a real issue with mental health in this country and I don't know if it's
unique to this country or if the problem is that these people that have these
mental health issues have more access to guns and they have another states or in
other countries rather,
but I don't think the issue is removing the guns.
I think the issue is trying to figure out as an advanced society with a nuanced
objective point of view,
why people would ever want to kill a bunch of people they don't know what is it
that is causing folks do that,
not what are the tools they're using to do that.
That doesn't make any sense to me and taking those tools away from people that
would never do that.
I know so many hunters and so many people that are gun enthusiasts that are the
nicest fucking people in the world and don't do a goddamn thing wrong every day
and to think that you can take away their rights,
the own firearms because one crazy person does something right.
What are we going to do?
Have crazy people just drive into crowds.
What are we going to do when someone stomps on the gas and heads towards an
outdoor mall?
Just plows over a bunch of people because they have demons in their head because
they didn't take their pills that day.
I mean,
we've got to take away the right to drive.
I mean it seems like we're going down that road anyway with these,
these cars that are going to be self driving.
I mean there's going to be issues involving the rights of people to just decide
to go out for a drive.
The second amendment is the right to self preservation.
You know,
when people go like,
well,
what are you good?
So when I came back when people had muskets,
right?
Why did a video on that?
You do realize that's completely on clues.
Penis,
small penis,
the puggle gun jeer and Doni air rifle,
Belton Flintlock,
you know,
there's guns could fire 30 rounds in a second,
or 20 seconds.
We have a,
uh,
a letter from,
I think it was Madison to a private ship,
but they said,
hey,
can we have canon is to stop piracy.
Second amended,
of course you can have canons.
So they knew as a of they had placed orders for some of these high capacity,
really advanced weapons.
It just wasn't cost effective for the American government.
When we're the second amendment drafted,
uh,
Gosh I don't,
I'm terrible with numbers,
but the puck Hogan and Abelton Flintlock and a,
a lot of these guns already exist in high capacity before the outlaw Josey Wales
Gatlin Gun.
Yes.
With the shit.
Yeah.
Well I did a video on it.
You can,
I'll send it to you afterwards.
But um,
December 15,
19 1791 bill of rights.
Okay.
Hm.
Interesting.
That's why I never do the numbers.
1791 they,
they their suck.
No,
let's be honest.
Google Belton,
Flint lock puck Hogan.
I is,
but Google is your Andoni air rifle.
That's what they used.
Outfit Lewis and Clark did you earned during your rifle.
Really?
Yeah.
Fascinating weapon.
Right?
There was a first off.
That's not the argument you want to get into because the first amendment doesn't
only apply to a printing press,
right.
It doesn't,
it will do lives.
Need didn't have the internet back then pull that feathers they wrote with
feathers.
You can't just put anything you want on a blog.
I mean,
that's really the argument,
right?
Isn't it the comic or you've had in this show,
how about fucking a hunter s Thompson?
I mean,
if anybody violated what a lot of people would think the first amendment to
Stanford,
that guy took real facts and added fiction to them.
Right?
And that was the first amendment.
I mean,
he was allowed to do that mean he caused a fucking political candidate running
for president to lose his mind because people thought that he was on Ibogaine.
The guy had mental breakdowns.
I mean,
you know the whole thing with Ed Muskie when Ed must be President,
Oh my God,
you've got to see the movie.
Is it fear and loathing?
What is it?
What is the documentary Gonzo,
Gonzo.
And then there's something else behind it.
Whatever.
It's a fucking fantastic documentary.
Now.
That's the moment,
right?
Favorite offers where I could have just lied.
Did you realize that?
I see people do that,
like where you like,
do you know this?
And I could have said,
yes.
People do that all the time.
Gonzo the life and work of Dr. Hunter s Thompson.
That's amazing.
It's an amazing documentary.
It's so fucking good.
But it goes into great detail about how he would just add fiction to stories.
He was a journalist,
but he would just make shit up.
And so he made this shit up about them bringing in a Brazilian doctor because
they knew that muskie had some,
I began an addiction and he,
and he goes,
there was a rumor going around,
you know,
and so he was on,
I think it was the Dick Cavett show.
It's a fucking hilarious interview.
And he goes,
well,
there was a rumor going around,
uh,
a Shard of the rumor.
Well,
like Lena Dunham,
I said,
perspiration problem.
Did you start that?
Everybody?
I haven't perspiration problem.
I came here from Yoga class,
man,
I was soaking wet.
He came from Yoga class.
Now that the second amendment goes back to the issue of you either believe in
self preservation or not.
And that's why I know Amy's a friend of yours.
But when she gets up there and she's pushing gun control every single show,
is she pushing those specifically when someone wrote about it like gun control?
I believe that crazy people shouldn't be allowed to have guns.
I,
I believe that if you have a history of violent behavior and a history of
violent crime,
you shouldn't be able to go to a store and buy a gun.
I bet you believe the same thing.
You don't want to misspeak as to what it is.
It's chuck is split.
Well,
I do think those things,
but I also going gonna lead,
right?
Well,
no,
because the,
now see that's one thing where everyone goes,
well yeah,
of course we don't want crazy people getting guys,
but do you really want the government then deciding who's mentally fit?
If you'd taken a Xanax,
you're not mentally fit you,
right.
Anxiety,
Nick Diaz and your prescription for anxiety,
marijuana.
You can't buy a gun.
No,
I don't.
I don't believe that we have the parameters yet realize that federally for the
longest time,
that was actually the case that if you did have a prescription for medical
marijuana you can because it's federally illegal,
you weren't allowed to have a handgun that would make you,
it wasn't allowed to have a rifle.
Well that would make sense.
I mean Barack Obama's,
you know,
federally prosecuted,
even people in Colorado where he's talked about that,
that he doesn't really want to leave that to the stage.
I don't want to get off on the pot thing cause we actually agree on that.
But the,
the gun thing is,
it's an instinct for self.
It's self preservation.
So a lot of these celebrities,
for example,
I get really bothered personally because I've had to put my wife under security
watch cause of angry Muslims and members and when someone like
yeah
you're one of those guys like a break something up and you go yeah that too.
Oh you have a bunch of people here saying I doctored footage.
I was punched in the face on national television for what happened.
I was at a right to work rally,
it was being passed in Michigan and I was there arguing with people in a drunken
guy wheeled me in the face and uh,
there were about 5,000 new members.
They tore down a whole tent for people who are pro right to work.
You can Google it and people will say the footage was edited,
but there's also 12 minute footage had to put up on my channel.
Um,
people trying to send you which union?
Oh is he,
it was a meeting of right to work versus you know,
you need a whole bunch of unions.
So,
um,
this was,
uh,
was a pretty,
pretty big deal when it happened.
And um,
it's funny my dad watched it cause if you go back and watch it,
people tried to say,
Oh,
you shoved that old guy down and then he sucker punched you.
It's like,
well if that's the case,
I was looking for a fight,
I would have fought,
but there's about 3000 people there and I was going to be torn apart.
Who said you shoved the old guy?
Just people.
It's a whole conspiracy in the internet.
And I have a 12 minute video online.
Well I will,
I don't even want to get in to everything there because you can't pay attention
to you.
And then how ironic.
I don't have the attention span.
So my point is if you go watch it and knowing that we talked about Jujitsu and
stuff,
my dance like did you have a collar elbow tie?
And when you're going for Gucci Man,
I'm like,
yeah,
it was.
So you see me grab him,
he's wailing.
You were ready to toss them.
And I turned my hips and you can see the footage.
I turned my hips in and then I see,
it's like,
oh shoot,
there's 2000 other people.
And so I just cover Watson.
Now we have to do this.
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
back the fuck up.
So that's a tent that got torn down and you backed up.
Well this guy came in the back,
the fuck up over.
So this is what they say.
And you know,
if you are,
there's a,
oh,
he's swinging.
So see I turned my turn my hips and then just duck my head and go back cause I
really like terrible technique.
Your,
your hips were too far.
Yeah.
Well I did it if it's tough.
Did you get hit?
Yeah,
I got hit full line baby punches though.
That guy has shit technique too.
It's terrible.
I can't even do commentary for this fight.
But you're not expecting it.
Fucking guy was windup up roundhouse punch is like,
God what an asshole.
I've said this before.
Why do people who can't fucking fight at all think they can get in fights when I
was getting drunk off second and fumes not,
you know,
sounds shit that I'm saying.
I was getting drunk off second and funeral.
He's hammered.
Oh he's handing all work.
Yeah,
go fuck off.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of footage there but a tow work right to the hate,
right to wear what?
What is right to work.
So you don't have to be,
that essentially means you don't have to be in a union to work.
Right.
Oh and they and so forth.
If there is a union,
like electrician's union or something like that.
So if there is a union,
yeah,
you,
you should join their union or not.
So we talked about that.
Well,
there's a real issue with the UFC,
I'm sure you're aware of it.
The culinary union issue,
that video on legalizing it in New York and did it a long time ago.
We reported on it.
And um,
matter of fact,
the UFC was Jennifer wink back then.
I was working there.
They were like,
I don't want to say they were very controlling until they realize that I wasn't
trying to sand bag.
I'm like,
listen,
this is what I'm talking about.
I understand the union,
uh,
the,
culinary union and a,
I want it to be legal in New York.
But even then they were like,
well,
can you send us a cut of the video before it goes up?
And I was like,
no,
I can't.
So I interviewed shale and interviewed pat and I interviewed,
um,
Hanzo and a hundred Gracie and we talked about it.
And that's what a lot of people don't understand.
The Culinary Union in Nevada and they're vendetta.
And we talked about Bob was it,
you know the senator,
Congressman Terry said the reason I'm against MMA and New Yorkers because it's
violent.
Yeah,
that douchebag.
Well he's gone now,
but you got to rescue a show when I was on a show in Albany doing a radio show
and he called in to argue with me and I wish he had no arguments for us.
But what about football?
What about Bob [inaudible]?
He's a corrupt politician.
I mean,
didn't he get busted for corruption?
Well that's it.
The same guy when we talk about big money in politics and we won't have time
cause I think it's all going to go soon.
Well,
no,
no.
When people say coke brothers are big oil,
big Pharma,
you look at the top political donors of all time,
15 out of the top 20 are unions.
And I got into this argument over Twitter with gray Maynard and usually just
like,
no bro,
it's corporate.
I ain't go listen.
You want to talk about corporation?
No Bro.
That's great man.
Or do you guys again?
Um,
and I was like,
listen,
these are the top donors they get.
No one wants to talk about big unions.
By the way,
they get virtually 99% to Democrats.
Big banks give 51% Republican,
49% Democrat because they're hedging their bets.
Unions,
often public sector unions,
you have no choice in whether you can join or not.
And he's non right to work states you joined,
they take your dues and intern that you,
those use those dudes to elect more Democrats who give them more kickbacks.
So I just think,
yeah,
there's a lot of money in politics,
but everyone wants to talk about big oil and big Pharma and no one wants to talk
about big unions,
which is a far more influential force.
And they get away with murder.
They'd get away with what seems to be a part of the same problem.
Right.
It's like people get addicted to the money that comes out of that establishment.
They get addicted to the money.
You know,
they,
that's what the culinary union,
they know that they can make something like $15 million a year if the station
casinos all went union.
Right.
And meanwhile,
the people that work in the casinos are voted against it.
Now,
I don't know the particulars of the case.
I don't know.
I don't know who's being told what to do,
but I know,
just know that is what the fact is.
They did vote and they voted to go non union.
But these fucking culinary union guys,
they been attacked in the UFC forever and they've been a lot of creepy shit to
the casinos that are nonunion.
They've set up shop outside these casinos and they were insulting people that
were walking into the casino.
Just patrons,
just regular customers shitting on this guys.
I mean there was this big thing on the video got released and the color in your
union looked horrible for,
of,
and it's,
I'm sure the unions are and people Nicole on or a union just like,
there's good people in every organization that's fucked ultimately.
But the,
the whole,
it's a mass man.
That's a mess that the unions in the Midwest,
those are the kinds of,
and that's how I was with my lawyers when we're dealing with this.
And there was a prosecutor in Michigan who was,
we found like almost all of his funding at that incident was the AFL CIO,
which is a big union.
Um,
and um,
matter of fact,
I was told there were about 50 people that day,
not just me.
He tried to file police reports because that whole tent you,
it was cut down with box cutters.
There's a black guy selling hot dogs who's thing was destroyed.
He was called the n word.
This whole thing happened that day.
I still have a piece of the tent and there were dozens of people tried to file
police reports and they said,
well,
we can't file police reports by phone.
It's completely absurd.
Of course he can.
If someone's raped in Florida and he moved back to Ohio,
you were on vacation,
you can call them and say,
my daughter was raped in Florida.
So a lot of people tried to file reports.
They weren't able to.
Uh,
a lot of people were in the tent when it went down and the same thing happened,
you know,
uh,
attack the Messenger.
Oh,
you,
you will.
You really had no business being there.
You were provoking it.
Here's the beauty about assault.
If I right here,
go,
Hey Joe Rogan,
I think you suck nanny,
nanny,
boo boo.
You can't hit me.
Guess what?
You still can't hit me.
Right.
That's the law,
right?
You're only allowed to hit someone if you really believe that your life or your
health.
Yeah.
So most of the time you kind of be hit first.
I mean,
it's hard to argue otherwise.
if two people are staring at each other and they're yelling at each other and
someone decides to throw the first punch,
that person is the antagonist.
That's the person who caused the issue.
Well,
there's mutual combat laws and all that stuff,
but,
well,
in Seattle it's in Washington state was the name of the Superhero Guy.
Yeah.
Well,
I'm a Phoenix Jones.
He's a good fighter.
Yes he is.
That's the fucking lake.
It's fucking very,
you'll see that when we were like mutual combat.
Yeah.
Let me just like kick in.
The guy stopped and that he,
the guy was like,
oh no.
Oh,
I've made a bad choice.
Yeah,
he's really good.
That's your problem.
What's the name?
Fuel door.
Uh,
Carlos photo or photo is,
is,
that's his brother.
His brother's a fighter too.
Yeah.
I don't know what his name is,
but know what is this?
He calls himself Phoenix Jones.
Right.
What is his real name?
He's a fucking very good fighter though.
You could say.
It's really almost mean.
You know,
there's walks around with a superhero.
It's not,
it's not fair at all because he's fucking good.
I don't want to fight.
I'm here to keep peace.
But you know,
deep down it's like gimme gimme a reason.
Yeah.
It's hilarious for him.
But he's been stabbed.
Like he's,
he's like,
he's had like legit issues.
Well yeah.
Broken up fights or stopped robberies and stuff.
Well,
the worst part is like,
there was one was like the domestic abuse case and um,
those were always got it.
Well,
cause it doesn't matter.
The woman's still going to protect your man even if it's wet.
And so he goes under step.
Right.
And then hey,
she's wailing on him.
You ever seen that will give you,
you do that one?
I don't even want to see it.
Domestic views,
abuse cases.
They fucking freaked me out cause I grew up more,
more women committed to men.
Really?
Yeah.
By far.
It's not even close.
What?
That's why there's something not even close.
Not even close.
Yeah,
but they don't do much damage.
That's the point.
Yeah.
We let him go.
Ronda Rousey admitted recently that she beat the shit out of one of her ex
boyfriends because she caught him taking pictures of her and everybody's like,
well,
fucking free pass.
First of all,
I believe it because it's Ronda Rousey.
Well on side.
She beat the fuck.
Well I know the dude,
he's actually a very,
he's a very good fighter.
He could find himself.
But when,
when Ronda Rousey says she beat dude's ass,
everybody goes,
I can see that.
But that's probably because of the Tom Jones Syndrome where he realized he was
wrong and took it.
And then you see her with the [inaudible] syndrome.
What's that?
He will have to famous calm Jones,
the singer Tom Jones.
He talked about when he cheated on his wife and she found out and she just beat
the hell out of them.
He's like,
I have to sat there and took it because I deserved it.
And that's usually what happens in domestic abuse most.
This is actually something you should have her on Karen Straughn what?
We talked about it.
Oh,
that girl writes what chick I really love to have her on.
She talked about it how,
you know,
men were unfair,
were have always been punished for domestic abuse.
It's not like it's ever been okay.
Uh,
Theodore Roosevelt,
I think it was Teddy Roosevelt in 1906 wanted to bring back the whipping post
for domestic abuse because he thought it was unfair to put a man in prison
because then he could no longer provide for his woman.
On the flip side,
if a man was domestically abused,
you were basically dragged to the street and shamed.
So,
um,
most men never reported,
dragged them to the street.
I mean,
they would parade you through.
You'd be reshaped bitch.
That's not policy.
Whipping posts was policy.
This is cultural sort of context.
Gotcha.
Um,
but yeah,
domestic abuse is actually higher and lesbian communities.
What?
Yeah,
yeah.
It's higher in lesbian can well per capita,
but there's not that many lesbians.
Right.
So I don't have a charge,
but I imagine there's,
yeah,
there's less confidence per capita as much I would wager.
Um,
so it's,
uh,
how much higher though?
I don't have the numbers in front of me.
It's like Jamie does Jamie look up domestic violence in the lesbian community.
It's not as much higher between the lesbian community and the straight community
as it is between women against men.
So women versus men.
Domestic violence is just reported domestic violence.
Women getting smacked around.
They don't report it.
Honest question.
Okay.
Your wife ever smacked,
you know,
she ever punched you in the arm?
No.
She's not like that.
Really?
No.
She's not like that at all.
She's super easy.
Gone Do.
My wife's like punched me in the arm.
I can't really up around violence and I don't like it.
I mean it sounds crazy talking to a guy as a cage,
fighting commentary has done,
done martial arts his whole life.
But I don't like violence.
I don't even know.
I don't like action.
I don't mind seeing it.
Like I don't lie.
I like fights and I've,
I've,
I've like always enjoyed competing.
I don't,
it's not that,
but that doesn't seem like violence to me even though it is.
That is,
uh,
you were,
you have a mutually agreed upon meeting of two very skilled people who are going
to try to impose their discipline,
their will,
their focus,
their technique,
their intelligence and their preparation on each other.
That's how I look at fighting.
Yeah.
It's what I don't like.
People that love each other,
hitting each other.
That shit drives me crazy cause I grew up with it and I don't,
I don't,
I would never date a girl who tried to photos.
Okay.
I don't want to make my wife's not a monster.
Beat your ass.
Fuck you up when my,
it's got rain,
she's six foot and she's got this,
she's got a log jam.
She was a runway model for years.
Um,
she like,
you know,
and,
and I milked,
it didn't hurt,
but you know,
it's a good example right here.
But you milk.
Yeah.
Milk that.
I went to the bar and left and I was like,
you know what,
I need to cool down.
I'm turning around like,
I'm like,
Gosh,
I've,
you know,
I can get whatever I want for the next week.
Terrible.
Don't do that.
It's bad for your marriage.
But it worked.
Um,
I will say this,
that a good example is like a dog.
I see little dogs get into fights all the time.
They don't hurt each other.
If hopper does it,
they take them away.
They take them away.
Of course he's never done it.
But I've had it,
he was bitten by a little Pomeranian.
And uh,
one time a dog did bite and it was the only time he actually had Blackford and
its teeth.
But here's the thing,
if hopper wanting to bite his Nike would have been his neck.
People don't realize dogs.
That's a clipping.
That's like the mom sound of the teeth.
That's to say back off.
But uh,
I,
you know my friend actually my producer gay Jared,
he's got a little,
uh,
Australian shepherd and they'll get into fights.
Home Gauge,
Jared,
is that what call them is Chris' name?
Gay claims isn't that good.
Juries to them.
Okay.
His Twitter handle is not gay.
Jared,
you're going to follow his,
it's not gay,
Jared.
That's his Twitter handle.
It's not g a y.
You can follow them and draw your own conclusions.
Legally.
I'm obligated to say he's not
another one.
There's a lot of those guys.
I see.
I think it's fucked up,
man.
I think it should be really easy to be gay then we would find out who the fuck
is who?
No,
no,
no.
I wouldn't have a problem with a real number says he's not.
Okay.
Let's see here.
National Violence Against Women Survey found that 21.5% of men and 35.4% of
women living with same sex partners experience intimate partner.
Physical plant includes gain.
That's,
yeah,
that's exactly what you're saying.
So that shows that lesbians or more likely to be up their partners.
Then gay men are comparable with 7.1 and 20.4% for men and women respectively
with a history of only opposite sex cohabitation.
That's crazy.
So what that says is that 7.1% of women have experienced domestic violence by
men,
but 20.4% of men have experienced domestic violence by women.
The good thing,
what that says to me is that I am not alone.
Okay,
but that's Massachusetts.
See that right there.
Massachusets is filled with monsters drunk.
Those women fucking Queen,
they beat your ass.
They're terrible people.
They're only the only chick that I ever had take a swing at me.
It was a girl that I dated from Boston.
Really?
She took a swing at me while I was fighting.
I was,
I was in the middle of competition back then.
Like I was,
I was taekwondo.
I was now his kickboxing.
I was fucking crazy.
Like in,
this chick took a swing at me and I watched it coming and I was like,
I don't even believe this is happening.
And I ducked under it and I grabbed a hold of her.
I'm like,
what are you doing?
Are you hitting me?
He's trying to hit me.
I,
those are the only time I grow ag.
You fucking quit.
They're monsters.
They drunk,
they eating potatoes and just fucking swinging at you.
That's why it's Massachusetts.
I'll bet you look at the rest of the country.
It's probably totally different numbers.
No,
I don't think it's totally remembers.
Speaking of kickboxing,
have you seen Guy Masco recently?
Yeah.
That guy's in great shape for his age.
Oh,
he's in very good shape.
He's on.
He's had some,
um,
some issues with the cognitive,
behave,
you know,
is,
is damaged from his fighting career.
But,
uh,
he's actually,
I have to have him on because we talked about this.
He's,
he's gone through some pretty unique therapy.
There's a guy in Dallas that's a doing some very unique therapy,
dealing with a lot of the cognitive issues that he had because it was a longterm
fighting career.
Well,
he's closer.
He's really taking my dad under his wing guy is,
he's a great dude.
He's a great guy,
but I know couldn't,
it's too of great guy.
He's a great guy.
He really is.
He's very intelligent and he's,
he's soft spoken.
He's just a really good person.
Yeah,
he really,
really is.
And he's been very,
very supportive of my father there.
And there've been like Jitsu,
politics and stuff.
So my dad actually moved there from another school and um,
I was just gonna say,
I mean to Jitsu politics.
How gross.
Well,
you know what it is now.
The world's longest talked about that.
Like,
I've been a,
I've been a blue belt,
frightened and I can't remember how long because I moved and they thought it was
like an act of disrespect and I had to compete to get my blue belt.
Joe.
I had to win.
It's like it doesn't mean much,
but I had to win Naga worlds at White,
which in Dallas,
which means you might have a few people coming in from like 15 states,
you know,
it might be 1215 people in your division,
you are likely sandbank.
Right,
right.
And then it was like we've had people who were demoted from a demoted,
demoted because of like you trained with other people.
So it's just one of those deals.
My Dad's are training two,
three years after me,
he got us kind to get away from any school that does that,
that there's only a few schools that do do that.
But God damn it when they do that,
it's so disrespectful and it's so bad for the whole overall community of martial
arts because it turns people off when they realize that there's that kind of
politics.
It's terrible man.
That mean Eddie Bravo experienced that for the longest fucking time because they
thought he was disrespectful because he was teaching no Guid Jujitsu cause he
decided to develop a GNOCCHI system.
Not even realize that he's fucking,
he has a black them to John Jacques Machado.
Okay.
And,
and he trained with the Gif forever.
Right.
It's not that he doesn't want to train with the gies trying to train mixed
martial arts fighters and he's developing a system that would work with mixed
martial arts competition,
which of course you can't work.
I will say though,
I will say this and I actually,
I think Eddie Bravo is an incredible grappler,
but there is nothing more frustrating than when you have a kid come in with the
long pants and he just wants to sit in rubber guard and doesn't know how to it
because he's read a book and he's like talking about is edible mushrooms.
You're like,
how about,
how about you learn a hip bump bitch?
You know what I mean?
And then,
sorry.
Well you're always going to have problems.
Yeah,
I call that the,
the blue belt hysteria syndrome.
I'll tell you what,
when I was a branch of him,
you going to get that?
Yeah.
It's fun.
It's fun to be a contrarian's fun to go against the ground holding here.
This poor rubber guard.
And that's actually a good example.
You know,
one of my Brazilian instructors can't stand Eddie.
Um,
and you can go,
you know what he thought?
What's rubber guard?
I tell you what is Nuno Schembri he's taken from Nino know Schembri train with
it.
And I know,
I know all kinds of projects.
That kind of stuff you have to deal with and you Jitsu.
Well that's people that are silly.
How much did you go away?
This Brazilian Jiu Jitsu instructor.
How much?
What?
How much does he weigh this guy that doesn't like Eddie?
Well,
you'd have to 10.
That's a problem that he's about one 70.
If they're the same.
Well even though fucking that he approached me tap and learn something from
everyone.
Yeah.
But guys who talk shit like that and they've never experienced it.
You roll with Vinnie Magallanes Vanga mini.
Mini Magallanes is about two 12.
Brazilians really hate him.
Yeah,
they do.
Cause he came out and said,
and Brazilians,
Brazil's a crap hole compared to the United States.
I like living here.
And you done on your country.
I what?
The fight.
It's like,
well,
you know what?
He was a fight to fight them about like if you ever want to actually do an
impression,
like there are different dialects,
but Diego Brandao just imitate him.
It's the most city.
He's got a good one.
There's a lot of Diego Brandao.
Yeah,
he's well.
He looked really good.
And his last fight,
he,
what did he the fuck did he fight?
He fought a Japanese guy.
Um,
oh yeah.
it was in Japan,
wasn't it?
Yes.
[inaudible] did he phone on?
Mitzi gunky is really,
that's the guy that's one 35.
[inaudible]
guys.
45 I'm a cruise massacred.
Right.
He fuck somebody up though,
man.
What the hell was it?
Oh,
the dude throws that crazy fucking front kick.
Yeah.
Who knows?
I know that Jim Cuno got fucked up in his last fight by Tony Ferguson too.
He's having a,
hey,
you know who doesn't have racial guilt?
Who?
Japanese people.
No,
they don't.
They don't,
you're never going to hear Japanese people say,
I don't care what my grandkids look like.
No,
no,
no.
Racist as fuck.
Bob Sapp put him on a billboard eating bananas.
Yeah.
They make them eat bananas.
They didn't give a fuck.
We never see them recommending like a
giant sex toy ran with it to the bank.
He ran with it to the bank and then ran out of the cage.
Close money.
We actually had an issue with them.
What the Yakuza,
you know,
they,
there was an issue where they wanted him to fight without a contract and he was
like,
oh,
I need a con.
I have to fight that.
We give you a Kentucky after the fight.
What?
Well,
let me say one thing about guy massacre and we have to go right and I think
we're up.
It's,
we're about three hours.
Sorry guy.
Masker I will say it's just because I was,
it's my home gym button just for one second.
It's arguable.
Antonio was Jerry Noguera and the Rona fights.
Those were really close.
Those could have gone either way,
right?
If you reverse those and the Vandelay Headbutt doesn't happen and it goes to a
decision.
So he goes in the list of top light heavyweights ever.
Well,
he's an excellent fighter.
You know,
I mean,
he was always an excellent fun,
no one mentions them in the mix.
Wow.
That's unfortunate.
He was an early adopter,
you know what I mean?
He was one of the guys that know the real early days of MMA and he was also like
one of the best,
you look at like his style of kicking his kickboxing style.
He's one of the best traditional kickboxing style guys that like got into MMA.
He had like a lot of like really good skills back then.
But the Vandelay headbutt was a big turning point.
I mean he was doing well in that fight before that happened and uh,
Vandelay headbutted him.
It was,
I'm not saying it would have won the fight.
No,
but I'm saying if he did get a couple of those controversial decisions and they
go the other way,
you put them right up there.
Right.
Guys like Tito and chuck and I mean he was doing well,
you know,
he was doing really well with chuck until that he got clipped,
which is when I was a monster back then.
He was really a monster.
It was,
it's interesting because chuck style back then was to take shots cause his chin
was so fucking sturdy to take shots and just stay in the pocket and blast you.
And then eventually that gave out the chin gave out and like he's the best
example of why you can't fight like that.
Like look at a guy who had a chin that was so amazing.
Imagine if chuck with that Chin fought like Tj Dillashaw fought and elusive fast
moving fast footwork style where it's very hard to hit but still had that
ridiculous power.
Yeah man.
I mean obviously they're different weight classes.
It would be very difficult for him to move like that.
But if you fought a more defensive oriented style with that punching power and
just utilize it sparingly at openings,
but then he wouldn't have been chocolate Adele that no shot knock out.
It's one of the words that the proceeds horrific.
Yeah.
Well the rich Franklin one was even more disturbing to me because it didn't look
like you get hit that hard and it just,
he just put,
his body was already done.
You can only hitting the button so many times.
Sorry,
I didn't mean to take you down a rabbit trail.
Yeah,
no,
it's true.
It's totally true.
It's,
and you know,
that's one thing that's like super important to tell young fighters.
You know,
I always say that mighty mouse is the best.
I really think he's the best fighter in the world.
Pound for pound.
And one of the reasons why he's a fucking guy doesn't get hit.
He's so slick and he moves so well and he's all about technique.
That's mine.
His last fight,
he goes,
look at me.
I'm pretty as a motherfucker come,
we'll five rounds.
I will say that bothers me because all the heavyweights don't have technique.
Here's one thing my dad and I talk about a lot.
The margin for error at heavyweight or light heavyweight is much less than a,
and maybe faster fact is.
Guess what?
You can take 50 shots at flyweight.
You take one shot wrong.
It happens.
There's a reason if you watch,
if you watch high level heavyweight Jujitsu,
they are fighting often to stay off the bottom.
Except for guys like Cyborg,
um,
because it's,
it's a whole different ballgame.
Elevating 250 pounds or getting hit by it.
So when people saying,
oh,
the heavyweights aren't as good technically I go,
actually the fact is you get hit,
you can't get hit once at heavyweight you have to be more invasive.
There's less room for error.
And it's not just because I'm a relatively big guy,
not,
you know,
I'd be a middle weight probably if I ever had the balls to fight,
which I don't.
But as someone who comes from a long line of heavyweights,
that's the first thing they say.
What if my dad runs over it more?
You're just big.
Well,
there is also the issue with gravity,
like the heavyweights have to deal with so much more gravity.
It's so much harder to move and it's just harder when you can bench one 50 all
day.
Yeah.
How often can you bench to 75 exactly.
Not a lot.
Not even Brock Lesnar can do that.
Like it's flyway.
Exactly.
And it's also like to find a guy who's a heavyweight,
like Muhammad Ali who would move like that.
That's one of the reasons why he was such an outlier.
Like nobody had ever seen a heavyweight.
They could dance like that and move around like that and like no one had
prepared for it.
Like Sonny Liston was like this plotting murderous puncher and really had no
answer for that stuff.
Right.
Because it's not supposed to exist.
Like a guy's not supposed to be that heavy and be able to move that good.
Yeah,
it's a lot harder.
But even him,
when he got older,
that shit went away too.
And the only thing that I really disagree with you on is a wonderful relievers.
You said what?
George St Pierre was a national treasury about to cross some lines,
said that he got out while the wolves are at the door.
Disagree.
My friend,
well he don't think he got out where the wolves are at the door.
Look,
I think George Saint Pierre has Johnny Henry hazing.
Well,
it's not just Johnny Hendricks.
He asked.
It's Robbie Lawler.
There's a lot of fucking really good fighters.
Robbie Lawler's lights in strike force.
It's not like he 85 he's fighting when he,
you know,
because people take,
it came down to all these fighters.
It's a lot of weight give up when you're at an elite level and he really wasn't
a 185 pound guy.
He's not even a big one.
70 he makes weight easily.
Whereas opposed to like Johnny Hendricks can even fucking make the weight
anymore.
They're going to make him go up to one 85 well that's a good friend of mine.
He talked about how law,
they would just come in,
barely warm up and just fight.
That was an animal.
He's not like a,
he's not methodical like George Saint Pierre.
No,
George,
I'd like his style better because George has style is so unpredictable and I
think that he really set the groundwork for,
for Assa hobbies or wizard.
He's one of the very best trainers in the world and for us has like brilliant
breakdowns of MMA and brilliant breakdowns of fights.
And when you talked to him about it and when he talks about training,
he talks about overloading guys' mind with possibilities and that's what George
did.
You never knew what the fuck he was going to do.
You know why he's wrestling is so good.
A lot people don't understand this.
There is no wrestling in Canada.
Well he trained his Russian nationals training question handles in the Canadian
Olympic team so it's not like we have some guy in the UFC who had some high
school wrestling experience.
Either you don't wrestle or you wrestle with the best in the entire country.
We saw so super open minded.
I did a little bit of training with George and he just listens to everything and
soaks it all in and you could see his mind working like a fucking computer.
The way he takes in technique and I,
you know,
we did a lot of work with John,
Donna her on his Jujitsu and he just seeks out people that are going to like
find little things that he can do better and he listens.
He doesn't have an ego about it at all.
That's because you don't know why.
Well,
I was dark.
It is inside that dark inside of my head.
The alien in see him come to get occasionally.
We got to get out of here.
This is where at a time,
we're three,
three hours in.
There's a lot of fun,
man.
You very much.
If you're in town,
we'll do it again.
For sure.
What happened?
Uh,
s Crowder on a,
on Twitter,
right?
Yeah.
Uh,
your youtube page or site is loaded with credit.
Knocked louder with Crowder 15.
All right.
Your Fox.
I'll see you soon.
Thanks everybody.
Bye.
Okay.